Hymn really told me a lot about how to love and how to be a man, especially how to be a man, you know, growing up with a very religious toxic abusive father was very difficult for me and so I really had my emotions.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》真的教给我很多关于如何去爱以及如何做一个男人，尤其是如何做一个男人。你知道的，在一个极度宗教化、有毒且虐待我的父亲身边长大对我来说非常艰难，所以我真的封闭了自己的情感。
I was thought it wasn't okay to cry, it wasn't okay to be vulnerable, but Ted taught me that and it was also being disabled, having cerebral palsy and autism, and he had taught me how to properly interact with people and how to read social cues and that stuff, so it made me become a better communicator, meaning become a better friend, it made me become a lover.
我曾经以为哭是不行的，脆弱是不行的，但泰德教会了我这些。而且作为一个残疾人，患有脑瘫和自闭症，他教我如何正确地与人交往，如何解读社交线索等等，这让我成为了一个更好的沟通者，意味着成为一个更好的朋友，成为了一个懂得去爱的人。
Not just in the romantic sense but in a proper platonic sense as well.
不仅仅是在浪漫的意义上，在恰当的柏拉图式的精神恋爱意义上也是如此。
So thank you Josh, thank you Carter, thank you Craig, thank you to the whole team.
所以谢谢乔什，谢谢卡特，谢谢克雷格，谢谢整个团队。
I will continue watching a show for a little, because it's wait for it, legendary.
我会继续看一会儿这个节目，因为——等等看——太传奇了。
I'm alone.
我孤身一人。
I won't be soon.
但我很快就不会孤单了。
You know, York City, when I see you.
你知道的，纽约城，当我见到你时。
Please permit me to tell you everything.
请允许我向你倾诉一切。
York City.
纽约城。
Wow.
哇。
Well, Alec, our producer warned us that was a crusher of a letter, and it certainly was.
好吧，亚力克，我们的制作人警告过我们那是一封重磅催泪弹，果真如此。
What a, what an extraordinary thing to to let us know.
真是，真是件了不起的事，能让我们知道这些。
Thank you so much for that.
非常感谢你分享这个。
I am Josh Ratner.
我是乔什·拉德纳。
Hello, welcome to another episode of How We Made Your Mother, where we discuss the television program, How I Met Your Mother, which ran from 2005 to 2014.
你好，欢迎收看另一期的《我们是如何创造你老爸老妈的》，在这里我们讨论从2005年播到2014年的电视节目《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
I played Ted Mosby on that show for all two underneath episodes.
在那部剧里，我在全部208集里都饰演了泰德·莫斯布。
The show was co-created by Carter Bays and my co-host, the beloved Craig Thomas.
这部剧是由卡特·贝斯和我的联合主持人、我挚爱的克雷格·托马斯共同创作的。
Hi, Craig.
嗨，克雷格。
Hey, Joshy.
嘿，乔什。
Boy, that one got me.
天哪，那封信真的触动了我。
that lot of really, really, really got me.
那封信真的、真的、真的深深触动了我。
I am so trying to recover to get it together, but I wanna be friends with that guy.
我正努力平复心情，把状态找回来，但我真的很想和那个家伙做朋友。
I wanna be friends with him too.
我也想和他做朋友。
He is our friend, we are friends.
他已经是我们的朋友了，我们是朋友。
And thank you so much for sharing that experience.
非常感谢你分享这段经历。
My God, I thought it would be our guest that would make me cry just having today's guest, but then Alec has to sucker punch us on the way in with this beautiful letter and now I'm like crying.
天哪，我以为今天的嘉宾会让我哭，只要有今天的嘉宾在就行，结果亚力克在开场时给我们当胸来了一拳，送上这封美丽的信，现在我都快哭了。
I thought simply having today's guest would burst into tears of joy.
我本以为仅仅迎来今天的嘉宾就会让我喜极而泣。
Well, we often have very special episodes of How We Made Your Mother, but today is a very, very, very, very extra, extra, extra, extra, extra special episode of How We Made Your Mother because we have the mother of all mothers, the director of the show, our beloved and forever friend Pam Friman is here.
好吧，我们的《我们是如何创造你老爸老妈的》经常有非常特别的单集，但今天是非常、非常、非常、非常、额外、额外、额外、额外、额外特别的一集，因为我们迎来了所有老妈的老妈、该剧的导演、我们挚爱且永远的朋友帕姆·弗莱曼。
Hi, Pam.
嗨，帕姆。
Oh my gosh, thank you so much.
哦天哪，太感谢了。
Hi, friends, that was, it was perfection.
嗨，朋友们，那真是，太完美了。
believe it?
敢相信吗？
It's so beautiful.
太美妙了。
The best part of this is hearing from the fans.
这其中最棒的部分就是听到粉丝们的心声。
That's really the show.
这才是节目的真谛。
It's a way to just talk to connect with people like what we just heard and what an honor to hear that the show met.
这是一种与人们交流、建立联系的方式，就像我们刚刚听到的一样，听到这部剧达到了这样的效果是多么大的荣誉。
All these years later, yeah.
历经这么多年，是的。
And it really does feel like we made a thing and you make anything, it's like you put a bottle out in the ocean and you just hope someone gets the message inside it.
真的感觉就像是我们创造了一件作品，而当你创造任何东西时，就像是把一个漂流瓶扔进大海，你只是希望有人能收到里面的信息。
And it really just feels like it belongs to the fans now and including, you know, there, there are all these theories, Pam, that we're hearing that we've asked Carter correctly.
而且真的感觉它现在属于粉丝了，包括，你知道的，有各种各样的理论，帕姆，我们听到后去向卡特求证。
Did you mean to do this?
你们是故意这么做的吗？
Did you mean to do this color scheme thing?
你们是有意设计这种配色方案的吗？
There's a whole conspiracy theory about the colors and what they mean.
有一个关于颜色及其含义的完整阴谋论。
And it's kind of like they didn't mean to, but they did on some subconscious level, you know, we're talking about dream logic here, right, Craig?
这有点像——虽然他们不是有意的，但他们在某种潜意识层面确实做到了，你知道的，我们这里讨论的是梦境逻辑，对吧，克雷格？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, there's something that comes out and like you hear crazy thing.
是的，有些东西自然而然地流露出来，就像你听到一些疯狂的理论。
And then you're like, actually, there's something, there is something kind of to that.
然后你会想，其实，这里面确实有点道理。
It's really, it's really cool that the show is like, is studied at that level.
这部剧能被研究到这种程度，真的很酷，真的很酷。
And by the way, just to back it all the way up here.
顺便说一句，我们把话题拉回原点。
Well, today's date, we'll talk a little bit about the episode and question that we're up to, which is Mary the Paralegal, which is really funny episode.
好吧，今天的日期，我们会稍微聊聊我们要讨论的那一集，也就是《女助手玛丽》，那真是有趣的一集。
But we'll also just talk about Pam, like, oh my God, how we met Pam, like, Pam, one of the earliest believers in this thing, Carter and I were these two little boys, These two guys, they were in fifth grade when we met you.
但我们也会聊聊帕姆，哦天哪，我们是怎么遇到帕姆的，帕姆是这部作品最早的信徒之一，卡特和我当时还是两个小男孩，两个家伙，我们遇到你时还在读五年级。
Short little pennies, little beanies with propellers on them.
穿着短裤，戴着带小风扇的小帽。
And we're like, would you read my script, little lady?
我们当时说：“小女士，你能读读我的剧本吗？”
You're pretty and seem like an adult sitting in a Starbucks, just with the two.
你长得漂亮，看起来像个坐在星巴克里的大人，就我们两个。
That is how we met Pam front.
这就是我们与帕姆·弗莱曼相遇的方式。
And we heard the like the script.
然后我们听了剧本。
And I was told, by the way, I was told to go meet these two guys at Starbucks and I walked in and there were all these tables and there were two guys at each table.
顺便说一句，我当时被告知去星巴克见这两个家伙，我走进去，发现有好多桌子，每张桌子旁都有两个家伙。
And I was like, what's your whole life could have changed if you went to the wrong table?
我在想，如果你走错了桌子，你的人生会发生多大的改变啊！
I know, they all had pilots to show you in Los Angeles that were written in that Starbucks.
我知道，他们在洛杉矶要给你看的试播集剧本都是在那家星巴克写的。
Pam, tell us what your experience was.
帕姆，告诉我们你的经历是怎样的。
Do you remember reading the pilot?
你还记得读试播集剧本的情景吗？
Right.
没错。
I certainly remember reading the pilot and it was unlike any other pilot and it was so funny but the heart got me, the heart got me.
我当然记得读试播集的情景，它与我读过的任何其他试播集都不同，它非常有趣，但真正打动我的是它的核心，是它展现的情感。
And it was just a show I wanted to watch more than anything.
那是这是一部我极其渴望看到更多内容的剧集。
So when the opportunity, then I was just lucky that they found me and that I got a chance to meet them and once you sit down with Carter and Craig, you're in, you're in.
所以当机会来临时，我很幸运他们找到了我，让我有机会见到他们。一旦你和卡特、克雷格坐下来，你就入伙了，你绝对入伙了。
Pam, one of the things we hear over and over again about the show, we're trying to uncover like, what is the enduring part of the show?
帕姆，关于这部剧，我们一遍又一遍听到的一件事——我们一直在试图找出这部剧经久不衰的秘诀究竟是什么？
And I think time and again, and we heard it in the opening, it's the heart part.
我发现一次又一次，我们在开场时也听到了，核心就是它的情感。
And you, as the director, guarded that so religiously, I think that aspect and said, don't sell it all out to the jokes, don't make it too snarky.
而你作为导演，非常虔诚地守护着这一点，我认为正是这种特质，让你对大家说：“不要把所有筹码都押在笑话上，不要让它变得太刻薄。”
You let moments breathe.
你要给情绪留出呼吸的空间。
Josh and I keep talking about this all the time about his performance on the show, like when Ashley Williams was on, we talked about their drum roll, please, like an episode like that.
乔什和我一直在谈论他在剧中的表现，比如阿什莉·威廉姆斯出演时，我们谈到了他们的倒计时（“倒数三二一”），诸如此类的一集。
And there's certain episodes of the show where I go, I'm proud of how few jokes there are in this episode.
剧里总有那么几集，我会想：我为这一集里只有这么少笑话而感到骄傲。
Meaning we let those emotional moments breathe, you seems to understand that that was the key to this show succeeding maybe before Carter and I did.
意思是，我们让那些情感时刻得以呼吸。你似乎比卡特和我更早明白，这是这部剧成功的最关键所在。
I don't know how much credit I can take.
我不知道自己能居功多少。
I just know what I loved and what resonated with me and with Josh Radner who put his hand on his heart and we once he did that.
我只知道我热爱什么，什么能与我以及乔什·拉德纳产生共鸣，他曾把手放在心口上，一旦他这样做——
When he made that move once, that was like our sign to each other for the next 200 episodes.
当他做出过那次举动后，那就成了我们俩在接下来200多集里彼此的暗号。
Yeah, you know, it's funny, Pam, when you say it was a show you wanted to watch, I have this experience sometimes whether or something gets sent to me as an actor or a director.
是的，你知道的，很有趣，帕姆，当你说是你想看的剧时，我有时也会有这种经历，当有什么东西作为演员或导演送到我面前时。
If I really love it, and there is that feeling like, I want to watch this, but I want to watch the best version of this.
如果我真的热爱它，就会有一种感觉：我想看这个，但我想要看这个的最完美版本。
And I love it in such a way that I might be the person that is the right person to bring this to life because I feel the heartbeat of it.
我对它的爱如此深切，以至于我可能正是把这个故事带入现实的正确人选，因为我能感受到它的心跳。
And it's almost like you step in because you want to protect it or you want the best version of it to come to life.
这就像是你介入其中，因为你想保护它，或者你想让它的最佳版本呈现在世人面前。
Was there something like, because at that point, you know, we can talk a little about your career, but you had your pick of pilots, right?
当时有没有这样一种情况——因为在那之前，你知道的，我们可以稍微谈谈你的职业生涯，但你当时有很多试播集可供挑选，对吧？
Like you were sending a ton of pilots, you could pick what you wanted to do and you landed on this one.
就像有大量试播集送到你手上，你可以挑选你想做什么，而你最终落脚在了这部。
And part of it, I sense is that you felt that pulse in it.
我感觉其中一部分原因，是你感受到了它内部的那次脉搏。
Well, I think that's all true.
嗯，我想这些都是真的。
And one of the great things about this is that Carter and Craig were very young, hadn't done it a lot.
其中最棒的一点是，卡特和克雷格当时非常年轻，没有太多经验。
And I knew that I could add some experience.
而我知道我可以贡献一些经验。
I could help them sort of ship.
我可以帮他们掌舵。
I could be the adult in the room a little bit.
我可以稍微充当一下房间里的大人。
And you guys, there were no rules.
而你们呢，当时根本没有规则。
You were just doing what you instinctively knew would be funny and would be beautiful.
你们只是在凭直觉做你们知道会很有趣、很美好的事情。
And we had craft service.
而且我们有剧组餐车。
You guys were more excited about that than I think any guy is all just, everything was just unbelievable.
比起任何一个家伙，你们俩对那件事的兴奋程度简直无以复加，一切都太不可思议了。
We got free food.
我们有免费的食物。
I didn't know that was gonna be part of it.
我都不知道这也是福利的一部分。
And I wrote you this little day to send you in New York City.
我给你写了这个小纸条，派你去了纽约城。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
And now, back to the show.
现在，言归正传。
was there any negotiation between these guys are actually like we talked that that some of the brilliance of it is they didn't know any better like they didn't know you couldn't do x y z but you you had been around the world of sitcoms and didn't you i mean you apprenticed with james burrows right like that was part of your kind of education of coming up or but it feels like you You were standing on the shoulders of people who, you know, that kept moving the form forward.
有没有这样一种磨合：这些家伙实际上——就像我们聊过的，它的一些精妙之处在于他们初生牛犊不怕虎，他们不知道有些事是不能做的（比如X、Y、Z），但你一直在情景喜剧的世界里摸爬滚打，不是吗？我的意思是，你曾师从詹姆斯·伯罗斯，对吧？那是你早期教育的一部分，但感觉就像是你是站在巨人的肩膀上，是那些人不断推动这种艺术形式向前发展。
And I think that how I met your mother really did move the form forward.
而且我认为《老爸老妈浪漫史》确实推动了情景喜剧形式的发展。
Was there any negotiation with, okay, these guys want to try to do something new, but also we have to honor the conventions of this thing at the same time?
这其中有没有过这样的协商与平衡：一方面这些家伙想尝试新东西，但另一方面我们同时又必须尊重这种形式的传统规范？
Was that ever attention?
这曾经是一种拉锯或矛盾吗？
I think so, and I think we weren't focused on the something new as much as making the best version of what was created, and when we went to do it, we realized that we couldn't rely on what we had done forever, that it was written in such a specific and such a different in such a great way that we ended up taking four days to shoot the pilot without an audience and decided that if we got picked up, we'd never get picked up, but if we got picked up, we probably have an audience.
我也这么认为，我觉得我们当时并没有把重心放在标新立异上，而是专注于把创意的最佳版本呈现出来；当着手去做时，我们意识到我们不能永远依赖过去的经验，它的写作风格如此独特、与众不同又极为出色，以至于我们最终花了四天时间在没有观众的情况下拍摄了试播集，当时觉得要是被砍了也就被砍了，但如果能通过，我们大概还是得有现场观众。
And then when we finished and it was picked up, it was like we want to show that you shot and in order to give them that show, we had to sort of, we had to make it a hybrid.
而后来当我们完成并获得预订时，感觉就像是“我们要展示你拍的东西”，为了呈现出那种效果，我们不得不把它做成一种融合体。
had to make it a multi-cam when it required it and make it a single-cam when it required it, stay inside, go outside, do all of these things that kind of blew up the convention of a multi-cam to serve how I met your mother.
在需要的时候做多机位拍摄，在需要的时候做单机位拍摄，留在室内，走到室外，做所有这些打破多机位常规的事情，来为《老爸老妈浪漫史》服务。
And that's what made it so unique.
而这正是它如此独特的原因。
Was that a tough negotiation?
那是一场艰难的谈判吗？
Do you remember with the studio network to throw out the live audience in tape night format?
你还记得跟电视台和制片厂沟通取消现场观众和录像带之夜形式的事吗？
Well, just to say, she had to explain it to me and Carter first, because Carter and I wrote this 70 page scene pilot.
嗯，应该这么说，她必须先向我和卡特解释，因为我和卡特写了一份70页场景的试播集剧本。
And we're like, we could still basically do this in front of our audience with a few pre-tapes.
当时我们觉得，我们基本上还是可以在现场观众面前演这个，只要加几个预录片段就行。
And like, Susie and Pam had to be like, let me explain how TV works to you guys.
结果苏茜和帕姆不得不对我们说：“让我来跟你们解释一下电视是怎么运作的吧。”
Kids!
孩子们！
Let me tell you something about television.
让我跟你们讲讲电视是怎么回事。
It's in your little eyes, kids.
全写在你们那双小眼睛里了，孩子们。
They sat us on the couch with kids.
她们把我们按在沙发上，就像对待小孩子一样。
And there was like so clearly no way it could be what it was on the page and shoot the traditional way.
当时很明显，根本不可能按纸面上的剧本以传统方式拍摄。
And you guys really had to explain that to us at a certain point.
在某个阶段，你们俩真的不得不向我们解释这一点。
Like, no, no, no, lean into it.
就像是在说，不，不，不，顺应这种形式吧。
It has to be something new.
它必须是全新的东西。
I remember I was actually in New York once we got picked up and I got a call from Dana Walden.
我记得在我们剧集获批后，我其实正在纽约，然后我接到了达娜·沃尔登的电话。
I stopped to get somebody to eat.
我正停下来买点东西吃。
I got a call from her and we had a conversation about audience and no audience.
我接到了她的电话，我们聊了关于有观众和没有观众的事。
And I said, if you want what you just saw, no audience and we'll make it work.
我说，如果你想要你刚刚看到的那种效果，那就不要现场观众，我们会把它做出来的。
And she was on board bringing it back to those quiet moments and the emotional moments in the heart.
她很赞同把那种安静的时刻、情感的时刻和内心的触动带回来。
I think that is a real positive side effect of not having a big bleacher full of 200 people to play to.
我觉得，不用面对满场坐着200人的大看台去表演，这是一个非常积极的副作用。
I really do think it makes a difference.
我真的觉得这大不一样。
Yeah.
是的。
We've talked a lot, Pam, on the show, about that there was something, it was tough to be inside of because you couldn't depend.
帕姆，我们在节目里聊过很多次，说身处那种环境其实挺不容易的，因为你没有依仗。
You know, the crew would laugh once.
你知道的，剧组人员只会笑一次。
They'd chuckle maybe again.
他们可能还会轻笑第二下。
And you were just having to trust that you were landing your jokes.
你只能凭信念去相信你的笑话能逗笑观众。
you had to almost hear the laughter like in your mind because the laughter was paped in afterwards, but I always maintain that it kept us from being overly amped up.
你几乎得在脑海里想象出笑声，因为笑声是事后后期录进去的，但我一直坚持认为，这让我们避免了表现得过于亢奋。
It kept us grounded in this almost like much more cinematic, realistic way.
它让我们保持了一种更接地气、更具电影感和现实感的方式。
So when we got to, we just did nothing good happens after 2 a.m., which is such a good episode and such a darkly funny episode without a ton of jokes, but it's the kind of episode where you have 18 episodes behind it, like pulling the arrow back on the bow and it just sails, so it's got so much momentum.
所以当我们拍到《凌晨两点后无好事》这一集时——这是一集非常棒、黑色幽默十足且没有大量笑话的剧集，但它是那种经过了前面18集铺垫的剧集，就像把弓拉满一样，顺势而出，所以它有着极强的势头。
But I think the kind of acting that's done between that me and Kobe were doing that me and Ashley were doing in that episode, it would be really hard to do that with 200 people eating sweet tarts.
但我认为，我和科比在、我和阿什利在该集中的那种表演，如果面对200个吃着甜心糖果的观众，是很难演出来的。
It was just a different vibe on the set.
片场的氛围就是完全不同的。
you know.
你知道的。
It was a completely different vibe.
那是一种截然不同的氛围。
The jokes, to me, the jokes would never have been satisfying for an audience because they happened on the edit so many times.
对我来说，这些笑话如果面对现场观众是永远不会让人满意的，因为它们在剪辑中被调整了太多次。
And it allowed us to have all of these sets and all of this time to get it right.
这让我们拥有了所有的布景和充足的时间来把事情做好。
And we always had great writers on stage as well as Cardone Cardone.
而且我们现场一直都有出色的编剧，卡尔顿和卡尔顿也在。
You could feel it.
你能感受到这一点。
And you guys were reacting to each other, which was so great.
你们俩当时在互相碰撞、互相回应，这太棒了。
And we all knew when we had it.
我们大家在拍出好效果时心里都有数。
And it happened so quickly.
而且一切发生得那么快。
It wasn't like we needed the first season to get the rhythm.
我们并不是非得用第一季来寻找节奏。
It just happened so organically.
一切都是那么自然而然地发生了。
And when you look at all of these episodes, because I've been watching with you guys, my God, that first season was unbelievable.
当你回看所有这些剧集时——因为我一直在和你们一起看——天哪，第一季简直不可思议。
It's good.
真的很棒。
It holds up.
经得起时间的考验。
It feels what it is right away.
一上来就找到了它应有的基调。
There's some real bangers in that first season.
第一季里有几集真的是王炸级别的。
We're pretty impressed with what we were able to do that for season.
我们对第一季能做到那种水平感到相当自豪。
Yeah.
是的。
Craig, can you just talk a little bit and maybe Pam too about the, it's not unheard of and I know, Pam, that you've actually done it yourself, but most television shows do not have a single director directing 99.9% of the shows that you have, maybe some in the first season and then you start cycling them in and the show has its own rhythm man in its own feel and so a new director has to be a part of that they are there they're serving that feel but this was a very very different situation can you talk a little bit about the choice to do that or Craig was it never a decision like Pam we just want you to stay forever please.
克雷格，你能简单聊聊吗？也许帕姆也可以聊聊——虽然这并非前所未有，而且我知道帕姆你其实自己也做过，但绝大多数电视剧都不会由单一导演执导99.9%的剧集，可能第一季会有一些导演，然后开始轮换，剧集有它自己的节奏和风格，所以新导演必须融入其中，他们来到现场，服务于这种风格，但这却是一个非常非常不同的情况。你能稍微聊聊当时做出这种选择的原因吗？还是说，克雷格，这根本就不是个决策，就像是“帕姆，我们只是希望你永远留下来，求你了”？
Oh I mean it was a hundred percent that I mean I can't explain the going back to that Starbucks for a minute when Pam walked in it was just like we love her.
噢，我的意思是，百分之百就是这样。我的意思是，说回到那一分钟我们去星巴克的时候，当帕姆走进来，那种感觉就是我们太喜欢她了。
We had heard every amazing thing about her that turns out to be true and then some when you really work with her and meet her.
我们之前听过的所有关于她的惊艳赞誉，等你真正和她共事、与她见面后，发现不仅完全属实，甚至有过之而无不及。
And then we, she was the in-demand, she was the bell of the ball every pilot season.
然后呢，她是炙手可热的人，每个试播集季里最耀眼的明星。
And everyone was like, you're not gonna get her.
每个人都说：“你们请不到她的。”
You're not gonna get her, you're not gonna get her.
“你们请不到她，你们请不到她。”
Pam has 20 other offers.
“帕姆还有20个其他的邀约呢。”
Why would she go with the script that like two 29-year-old guys who've never run a TV show wrote, maybe were just 30?
“她凭什么要选那个由两个从没制作过电视剧、29岁的小伙子写的剧本——也许当时刚满30岁？”
Why would she choose what kind of idiot would she use that one to direct?
“她怎么会选那个，得有多傻才会选那个来执导？”
And it turned out, Pam was like...
结果呢，帕姆的反应是……
Do you know what it is?
你知道这是为什么吗？
It's another love story connected to this show because for me, and I fell in love and it turned out I didn't want to share it with anybody.
这又是与这部剧结缘的另一段爱情故事，因为对我来说，我坠入了爱河，结果发现我不想跟任何人分享它。
And I wanted to be there every week.
我想每周都待在那里。
I mean, every day driving onto that lot was the best experience.
我是说，每天开车驶入那个片场都是最棒的体验。
I mean, it it it it was, you know, something you I think helped the whole cast and I'm and I'm sure Carter and Craig with was because you had had such a sampling of the many varieties of how TV shows can be how the what the egos can be like what the schedule can be like and you were constantly reminding us this is wonderful like I had less to compare it to you know and and it And it was really like you, there was this con, in addition to all the other many incredible things you were doing just professionally, just personally, you would pull us aside.
我的意思是，它，它，它，你知道的，我认为你对整个演员阵容——我相信卡特和克雷格也一样——都有很大帮助，因为你曾亲身体验过电视剧的各种不同制作方式，见过各种各样的人格有多自负、档期可以有多么繁琐，而你一直在提醒我们：“这太棒了。”（相比之下）我能比较的东西更少，你知道的，而且，而且真的就像你一样，除了你在专业上、个人生活上做的所有其他许多不可思议的事情之外，你还会把我们拉到一旁。
And it was always like, remember like to pinch ourselves, this is a really good job.
那种感觉总是像：提醒我们掐自己一下，这是一份非常好的工作。
We have something very special here.
我们在这里拥有非常特别的东西。
And your presence and fidelity and dedication to the show, the fact that you didn't want to go anywhere when you could have been anywhere else was a signal to us like, oh, this is a good gig.
你的存在、你的忠诚以及对剧集的奉献，明明在别处有无数选择却哪里都不愿去的态度，对我们来说就是一个信号：噢，这是一份好工作。
is like something to really take seriously, there's something to value, this is something to just feel very grateful for.
这真的是一件需要认真对待、值得珍视的事情，是一件让人感到无比感恩的事情。
And I'm grateful for you for helping me stay in that space.
我很感激你帮我保持了那种心态。
It was lovely to be able to sort of parent the five of you, especially my friend Joshua in the beginning.
能够像长辈一样照顾你们五个人，尤其是刚开始时的我的朋友约书亚，感觉很美好。
And me and Carter too, we were all the same age.
我和卡特也是，我们当时都差不多大。
Yeah, but in the beginning Joshua, I remember it was so overwhelming to say, you're gonna be on a show, and people are gonna stop you in the street.
对，但在刚开始时，约书亚，我记得那种感觉太压抑了，（我们要对他说）你将出演一部电视剧，人们会在街上拦住你。
It's a lot, it's a lot.
这压力太大了，太大了。
Yeah, and I think especially, it was, you know, Kobe was new to it, but there was something, I don't know, there's something about Kobe, she's just a little to the man or born, you know, like she just kind of stepped into it a little more effortlessly than I did and Ali and Neil and Jason had had, they had had public things, they had had people stop them in airports and on the street, they were a little more used to that.
是的，而且我觉得尤其是，你知道的，科比虽然是新人，但有某种——我不知道，科比身上有一种特质，她简直就像是天生吃这碗饭的，你知道吗？就像她比我、比阿里、尼尔和杰森更加游刃有余地融入了这一切。他们过去都经历过公开露面，有过在机场和街上被人认出的经历，他们对那种情况稍微更习惯一些。
This was my first go at this.
而这对我来说是第一次经历。
This was my first, you know, when I did the graduate, I was famous on a half block of West 45th Street from, you know, 10 o'clock to 10, 15 every night, and then I rounded the corner and I was back to being anonymous.
这是我的第一次，你知道的，当年我演《毕业生》时，在西45街只有半个街区那么大范围里，每天晚上从10点到10点15分我是个名人，然后一拐过街角，我又变成了默默无闻的路人。
So, you know, this was really new to me and it was very destabilizing, as you remember, and you were really, you couldn't have been more kind and loving to me throughout all that.
所以，你知道的，这对我来说真的很新鲜，而且非常让人心神不定，正如你所记得的那样，而你在经历这一切的过程中，对我给予了无比的善良和关爱。
And also, I remember very strongly you telling me, this isn't going to give you everything you need artistically.
另外，我清楚地记得你曾对我说过：“这不会满足你艺术上的全部需求。”
you're gonna have to do other stuff to supplement this wonderful, wonderful job, which really edged me into making my own movies and really creating this kind of multi-hyphenate life that I live now, today.
“你还得做点别的事来补充这份美好得无以复加的工作，”这番话实际上促使我去拍摄自己的电影，并真正开启了我如今所过的这种身兼多职的生活。
So just endlessly grateful to you.
所以我对你感激不尽。
You know how much I love you, but I'd like to say I'm already.
你知道我有多爱你，但我想说我已经准备好了。
And I'm wildly proud of you.
我对你感到无比的骄傲。
Well, I felt undermined by you the whole time.
好吧，我感觉这一路上我一直在被你拆台。
That's good.
这挺好的。
Do you remember, we talked about it.
你还记得吗，我们聊过这个。
Do you remember meeting me?
你还记得我们初次见面吗？
Let's talk about meeting me.
我们来聊聊初次见面吧。
You do.
你当然记得。
I do.
我记得。
What was that like?
那是什么感觉？
I remember that whole process.
我记得整个过程。
It was just so fun to read something and then to meet you and go, yes, yes, because you lead with your heart, you always lead with your heart and it's talk about a tricky role to play.
读到剧本然后与你见面，那种感觉太有趣了，心想：就是他，就是他，因为你是用心在引领一切，你总是用心引领，而且这真是一个颇具挑战性的角色。
Well, it was also, we've talked about it, but I was the first person on the first day of auditions, which must have been a little weird to go, wait, I think this is the guy, but we haven't seen any other guys, right?
嗯，这也是——我们聊过这个，我是第一天试镜时的第一个人，当时感觉一定有点诡异，心想：等等，我觉得这可能就是我们要找的人，但我们还没见过其他任何人呢，对吧？
Gosh, I remember all of those auditions.
天哪，我记得所有那些试镜。
I remember Neil coming in and throwing himself against the wall and all that crazy stuff.
我记得尼尔走进来，把自己往墙上撞以及所有那些疯狂的举动。
Do you think we've been talking a little bit about, I think that sometimes we overvalue effort and we overvalue things like a struggle or I saw a thousand people before we found our person.
你觉得我们是不是一直在谈论——我觉得有时候我们过分看重努力，过分看重诸如挣扎之类的东西，或者“我们在找到合适的人选之前面试了成千上万个人”。
Sometimes when things are right, you almost have to kick the tires a little bit to see because sometimes you're like, how could it be that easy?
有时候当一切都很顺利时，你几乎得去挑挑毛病、一探究竟，因为有时候你会想：怎么会这么容易？
How could the cast just come together so perfectly?
演员阵容怎么能如此完美地凑到一起？
How could Craig loves Buffy?
克雷格怎么会喜欢《吸血鬼猎人巴菲》？
How did Ali say yes?
艾莉怎么会答应？
There were just certain things that dropped into place in a somewhat effortless way.
有些事情就是以一种毫不费力的方式各就各位了。
It can be hard, I think, to trust that.
我想，要相信这一点可能会很难。
But I think in this case, it was to be trusted.
但我觉得在这个案子里，这是值得信任的。
The right people signed on for the right roles.
对的人签约出演了对的角色。
It was absolutely to be trusted and and what we what we learned was that the the effort was taking this gargantuan series and fitting it into three days Hats off to Michael Shea and Susie and everybody else, but that was to get it done was Was really something and and we did every week every week Yes, and thank you, Pam, for not being scared off by how ambitious the show was.
这绝对是值得信任的，我们学到的是，我们所付出的努力就是把这部庞大的剧集塞进三天里完成。向迈克尔·谢伊、苏西以及其他所有人致敬，但要把它拍完，真的太了不起了，而且我们每周都这么做，每周都如此。是的，谢谢帕姆，没有被这档节目的雄心壮志吓退。
It was written so recklessly and was such like a band-aid, like kind of guile-less, you know, abandon.
它的剧本写得太随性了，就像打补丁一样，带有一种没心没肺的、你知道的、随心所欲的劲儿。
Like we didn't know any better.
就像我们什么都不懂一样。
So we just wrote what we wanted to see.
所以我们只是写了我们想看的东西。
You could have seen that and been like, who the hell are these guys and run screaming from it?
你本可以看了之后说：“这群人到底是谁啊？”然后尖叫着逃跑。
Even after the pilot, like the pilot, four day big beast of a shoe, you're like, no, I want that challenge.
甚至在试播集之后，比如试播集，那是一个历时四天、难度极大的庞然大物，你会觉得：“不，我想要这个挑战。”
Susie was the same way.
苏西也是这样。
Our whole creative team and the cast were just up for the challenge.
我们的整个创意团队和演员阵容都欣然接受了挑战。
And I think Josh was right.
而且我觉得乔希说得对。
There was something effortless about it was like this script was its own little magnet that drew people to it.
这里面有一种不费吹灰之力Е的感觉，就像这个剧本本身就是一个小磁铁，把人们吸引了过来。
It was bigger than Carter or me or any of us.
它比卡特、我或我们任何一个人都要宏大。
And it was like, God, it just felt a little bit magical.
这就好像，天哪，感觉有点像魔法。
I mean, it did.
我是说，确实如此。
It felt magical.
感觉就像有魔法一样。
It felt like it called the right people.
感觉它召唤了对的人。
And you realize that, you know, nine years is a long time and there are always so many changes behind the scenes.
你会意识到，你知道的，九年是很长的时间，幕后总会有那么多的变动。
There were so few changes on our show, specifically on stage.
但我们的剧组，尤其是片场，变动太少了。
couple people, you know, we lost a couple of people, but everybody wanted to be there.
少数几个人，你知道的，我们失去了几个人，但每个人都想留在那儿。
Everybody.
每个人都想。
And when there was something tricky to shoot, everybody's hand moored up.
每当有什么棘手的镜头要拍时，所有人的手都举了起来。
Can I?
我可以吗？
Let me do it.
让我来吧。
Yeah.
好啊。
Let me do it.
让我来。
It was, it was like, we, you know, we owned it.
这就好像，我们，你知道的，我们把这当成了自己的事。
We owned it.
我们全身心投入。
This is just, I haven't thought about this in years, but Chris, was Chris camera a, not not Chris, uh, um, Chris Condi, yes, Chris Condi was X.
这只是……我好几年没想过这个了，但是克里斯，克里斯是A组摄影师吗？不对，不是克里斯，呃……克里斯·康迪，对，克里斯·康迪是X组。
Yes.
对。
She was next camera, yeah.
她当时是副摄影，对。
So I remember when there were three cameras going and her camera wasn't on, she would always like frame up something really beautiful to look at.
所以我记得当有三个摄影机在拍而她的摄影机没开时，她总是会构图一些非常美丽的画面供人欣赏。
Always.
总是这样。
Like an incredible like a portrait or like a shot that you just, there was such like, she's literally like stepping away for a shot.
就像一个不可思议的肖像，或者一个你一眼看过去的镜头，那种感觉太……她实际上就像是退到一旁不去拍镜头一样。
Like she doesn't need to be there because her camera is not on.
就像她不需要在那儿，因为她的摄影机没开。
But she would give you guys something at the monitor to look at.
但她会给监视器前的你们一些好看的东西。
And I always thought that was like, something so sweet and delicate and beautiful that didn't need to be done.
我一直觉得那是一件非常贴心、细腻且美好的事，其实完全没必要这么做。
Pride of ownership.
对作品的骄傲感与主人翁意识。
Right?
对吧？
It was kind of like, we were trying to create an environment that was beautiful.
这有点像是，我们在努力营造一个美丽的环境。
Because of you guys, everybody on that stage felt lucky.
因为有你们，片场里的每个人都觉得自己很幸运。
Everybody felt lucky to be there.
每个人都觉得自己能身处其中是件很幸运的事。
Right, right, right.
没错，没错，没错。
Did you ever kick back like a Friday night, late at night and go, Jesus, I can't believe how much we shot in three days.
你有没有过在周五深夜，夜深人静的时候，往后一靠，然后说：“天哪，我真不敢相信我们在三天里拍了这么多。”
Yeah, seriously, almost every Friday night.
对，说真的，几乎每个周五晚上都这样。
And often every week, yeah.
而且通常每周都如此，是的。
Yeah.
对。
But you were busy reading the next script going, wait a music video, wait, yeah.
但你又忙着看下一集剧本，心里想着：“等等，还有音乐录影带？等等，好吧。”
Where are we in a mall?
我们在商场里吗？
We're in an 80s mall, but it's the 90s in Canada, ostensibly, like everything we did was so confusing.
我们在一个80年代的商场里，但在表面上它却是在90年代的加拿大，基本上，我们做的每件事都让人觉得匪夷所思。
And you're like, yep, let's do it.
然后你会说：“好吧，开干吧。”
We got this, we have a plan.
我们搞得定，我们有计划。
Yeah, we could not scare you.
对，我们吓不倒你。
We could not scare you away.
我们没能把你吓跑。
And oh, how we tried, just so many times without our ambition.
而且天哪，我们是多么努力地想要吓跑你啊，仅仅是因为我们那过剩的野心。
Are there any episodes, whether it's for season or from any season that you just kind of like are just top three moments on how I met your mother.
有没有哪几集，不管是哪一季的，让你觉得可以排进《老爸老妈浪漫史》里最棒的三个瞬间？
Like, I always think about us dancing in the rain for some reason after the hurricane episode.
比如，不知为什么，我总是想起我们在雨中跳舞的场景，就在飓风那集之后。
I mean, there's so many moments, but drum roll please that you did not that long ago.
我是说，有太多的时刻了，但请敲起鼓点——这是你不久前才做过的。
I mean, can you beat that?
我是说，还有什么能比这更好？
I remember you coming into my trailer and insisting that Ashley and I watch it after you got the cut.
我记得你走进我的拖车，坚持要我和阿什莉在你看完剪辑版后一起看。
Isn't that funny?
这不是很有趣吗？
Yes.
对的。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
There are way too many moments, really way too many moments to list, and that was part of what kept me there, there were constant moments where I would, as we were watching the katsu, it would be like, look at what we did, look at what we did.
精彩瞬间实在太多了，真的多到数不过来，这也是让我留在剧组的原因之一，总会有源源不断的时刻——当我们看着粗剪版时，会忍不住说：“看看我们做了什么，看看我们做了什么。”
And it just talked me through this like, so would Sue do her own kind, like a rough assembly, right?
你给我讲讲这个流程吧，苏会先做一个粗剪版本，对吧？
And then who would watch it next?
然后接下来是谁看？
Would it be Carter and Craig would watch it next?
是卡特和克雷格接着看吗？
Oh, that would be you.
哦，那得是你。
So you'd get a director like a pass, like a director pass.
所以你会进行导演剪辑，就像导演剪辑版那样。
Exactly.
没错。
And I would never call a Sufetterman cut rough man shoes, yeah.
我可从来不会把苏·费特曼的剪辑叫作粗剪，哥们儿，真的。
The multiple Emmy winning Sufetter.
那位多次获得艾美奖的苏·费特曼。
Unbelievable.
难以置信。
But she had so much stuff to go through.
但她要处理的东西太多了。
A lot of the time as we would talk beforehand.
很多时候，我们会在事前进行交流。
so I could give her a heads up on, you know, certain things.
这样我可以就某些事情给她提个醒。
But yeah, it was me and that it was the guys.
不过是的，就是我和她，然后还有这几个伙计。
And was a lot of that cutting or tweaking or?
那其中有很多剪辑或调整的工作吗？
Yeah, yeah, it was, I actually did this, look for this shot, look for this, what if we do this, what if we pull this up or, you know, it's just, it's a director's cut.
对，对，确实有很多，我当时会做这些：“看这个镜头，看这个，如果我们这样做会怎样，如果我们把这个提上来，或者，”你知道的，这就是导演剪辑版。
Do you have weird, without Janet's like scripty book?
如果没有珍妮特的那本剧本记录册，你们会不会觉得怪怪的？
Do you, remember there was that fame, I don't know if you guys know this, but there's that famous press conference after LeBron had a game and someone asked him about a shot.
你们记得那个著名的名场面吗？我不知道你们知不知道，但勒布朗在打完一场比赛后有个著名的记者会，有人问他关于某个投篮的问题。
And he said, well, you have to go back to, and he went back like eight plays in the game, and he described everything that happened up and down the court for like eight plays.
他说：“嗯，你得回溯到……”然后他一口气倒叙了比赛中的八个回合，描述了这八个回合中球场上下发生的每一件事。
And you realize, oh, he's an actual genius of basketball.
然后你会意识到，哦，他真的是个篮球天才。
Like he has photographic memory of every play leading up to the whatever play they're asking about.
就像他对他们被问到的任何一个进球之前的所有战术都有摄影般的记忆。
And did you have that kind of recall?
你们也有这种回忆能力吗？
Like if you would see something, I would have this in movies where that I directed where I go, no, no, no.
比如如果你看到什么东西——我在我导演的电影里就会这样，我会说：“不，不，不，我记得莉齐·奥尔森左眼流下了一颗单薄的泪珠，我们必须把它找出来，我知道它就在里面。”
I remember Lizzy Olson had a single teardrop down the left eye.
（注：前文同义合并，此处为上一句延续）
We have to find it.
I know it's in there.
（注：前文同义合并，此处为上一句延续）
Did you have that where you would would remember?
你们也会有这种能记住细节的时候吗？
Absolutely.
当然。
Don't ask, don't ask me now.
现在别问我，现在别问。
But at the time, absolutely, because you, you do, you're sitting there.
但在当时绝对有，因为你会坐在那儿。
You're watching everything.
你注视着一切。
I've written things down.
我都写下来了。
I've taken notes and I'm so in it.
我做了笔记，而且完全沉浸其中。
But now when I'm watching these shows, as, as you guys are going through them, I'm like, oh my God, I felt so much, I have forgotten.
但现在当我看着这些节目，随着你们一起回顾时，我想，天哪，我感触太深了，我都忘了。
And yet, I remember where the sets were on the stage, like the placement.
然而，我还记得舞台上布景的位置，比如它们的摆放。
It's like, you know, it's, yes, the answer to that question is yes, at the time, for sure.
这就好像，你知道的，是的，那个问题的答案是肯定的，当时绝对是这样。
Yeah.
是啊。
Pam, one of your superpowers, I think, was making the cast feel so safe, I think.
帕姆，我觉得你的超能力之一，就是能让演员们感到非常安心。
And also making Carter and I feel safe to try stuff.
而且也能让我和卡特感到安心去尝试各种东西。
And again, you were one of the earliest votes for this pilot.
再说一次，你是这个试播集最早的投票支持者之一。
You were one of the earliest people who put their hand up and said, yes, this will work at a time when we didn't know what we were doing.
你是最早举手说“这行得通”的人之一，而在当时，我们甚至不知道自己在做什么。
You gave us a lot of confidence.
你给了我们很大的信心。
Did you, how do you, how do you do that?
你，你是怎么做到这一点的？
It's just a natural talent of yours.
这简直是你与生俱来的天赋。
Like you had the ability with these five new people in this show, and we even talked about this with Ashley Williams, kind of parachuting in in the middle of the season, needing to join a cast.
就像在这个节目中，面对这五个新人时，你有这种能力，我们甚至和阿什利·威廉姆斯谈过这种感觉——有点像在季中空降加入一个演员阵容。
You had such an intuition of who needed to hear what when, who needed encouragement.
你有着惊人的直觉，知道谁在什么时候需要听什么话，谁需要鼓励。
If you had to dial something back, is that just like, can that be taught?
如果你需要让某人收敛一点，这，这能教得会吗？
You just have this like a very empathetic, intuitive sense of people, I think.
我觉得你对人有一种非常富有同理心、极其敏锐的直觉。
I'm a mom.
我是个妈妈。
I mean, that's kind of a lot of it.
我是说，很大程度上是因为这个。
And I really didn't.
而且我真的没有……
I mean, that's who I am.
我是说，这就是我。
That's how I approach things.
这就是我处理事情的方式。
I'm, I guess I nurture and I really, I know it sounds so tried, but I, I loved these five act.
我，我想我是有养育和包容的天性，我知道这听起来很陈词滥调，但我，我真的很爱这五个演员。
I, I, they're a part of me and we fell and I want to take care of them.
我，他们是我的一部分，我们一同经历低谷，而我想照顾他们。
And I do believe that if you nurture that kind of a relationship and they know that they are seen and heard and valued, they want to be there.
而且我相信，如果你悉心维系这种关系，让他们知道自己被看到、被听到、被重视，他们就会想要留在这里。
They want to do their best work.
他们会想要展现出最好的一面。
All of that.
所有这些。
And I mean that for everybody.
我的意思是，这对所有人都适用。
It is such a team sport.
这真是一项团队运动。
And it's just such a lucky seat to be in for me.
对我来说，能坐在这样一个位置上真是太幸运了。
me.
我。
I can't tell you how grateful I am and people are still coming up to me to say great things about this show.
我无法表达我有多感激，人们到现在还会跑来对我说这部节目的好话。
It changed my life in such a beautiful way.
它以如此美好的方式改变了我的人生。
It's just, and here we are together in 2025 because we still love each other and because what we did still resonates.
就是这样，而我们在2025年齐聚一堂，因为我们依然彼此相爱，因为我们所做的事依然能引起共鸣。
I mean, my god, how lucky is that?
我的天哪，这是多大的幸运啊？
Had this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you, new York City.
有个老头，他一定……我爱上了你，纽约市。
And now, commercials!
好了，广告时间！
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈尔德曼，《Hyper-Fixed》播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会倾听听众的烦恼并试着为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如这样的问题：我30岁了，但害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我在倒车时不能调节车载音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们也解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你有什么烦恼，我们不仅会帮你解决，还会揭开导致该问题的幕后隐藏机制。
That's the HyperFixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这就是来自Radiotopia的《Hyper-Fixed》播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts, or at HyperFixedPod.com.
请在各大播客平台或访问 HyperFixedPod.com 收听。
And of commercials, back to Shell.
广告结束，言归正传。
Well, we're so constantly struck by the meta kind of quality of we were making a show about a guy's memories about these very special times that imprinted on his heart, these moments that were worth remembering and worth telling about and worth passing onto his kids.
嗯，我们经常为这种“戏中戏”的元叙事特质所打动：我们当时在制作一个关于某个男人的回忆的节目，关于那些铭刻在他心头的特殊时光，那些值得铭记、值得讲述、值得传给孩子们的时刻。
But we ourselves were imprinting these memories of the making of this show upon our heart at the same time.
但与此同时，我们自己也将制作这部节目的回忆深深铭刻在了心头。
Like it exists on so many different strange levels of meaning what this show is.
就像这部节目在如此多奇异的意义层面上存在着。
And I just wanna say vis-a-vis, You know like the way you needed to talk to the all five of us those are five different languages Like you didn't talk to me and Neil the same way you didn't talk to Ali and Jason the same way Like they're there everyone requires a different kind of handling or needs to be seen or appreciated in a different way Including the crew including every single person on that set and I did think that you were You have and this is not something that can be taught.
我只想说，就比如说……你知道的，你需要跟我们五个人沟通的方式，那是五种不同的语言。比如你跟我说话的方式和对尼尔的方式不同，你对阿里和杰森说话的方式也不同。就好像，每个人都需要不同方式的关照，或者需要以不同的方式被看到、被欣赏。包括剧组人员，包括片场的每一个人。我真的觉得你拥有……而且这不是能教出来的。你无法为此获得一个艺术硕士学位，你知道的，比如如何看懂一个房间的气氛，如何看懂一个人。
You can't get an MFA in this you know, like how to read a room, how to read people.
你无法为此获得一个艺术硕士学位，你知道的，比如如何看懂现场气氛，如何看懂人。
And I just thought it's one of your real superpowers of helping people feel seen and heard so that they can do their best work, because we've all had experiences where we don't feel that.
我只是觉得，这是你的超能力之一，能帮助人们感到自己被看到、被听到，从而让他们发挥出最好的水平，因为我们都有过没有这种感受的经历。
And I clench up, I get like, I can't actually do my best work.
而我会变得紧张，我会觉得……实际上无法发挥出最好的水平。
So I'm just so grateful to you for that.
所以我为此真的非常感激你。
I did wanna ask you, directing a show like this or even directing more generally, is, I don't think a lot of people understand it, generally directing, I don't know.
我确实想问你，导演这样一部剧，或者甚至更广泛地谈导演工作，我觉得很多人其实并不真正理解，广义上的导演工作，我不知道。
I don't know.
我不知道。
I don't know a lot of people understand what the job is.
我不知道有多少人真正理解这项工作是什么。
Do you have a way to describe your job or how do you describe it?
你有什么方式来描述你的工作，或者你是怎么描述的？
Like when people who really don't know what it is, like what would you say you do?
当那些完全不懂的人问你时，你会说自己是做什么的？
I get it done, I get it from the script to the TV, in a very general sense.
我把事情搞定，从最宏观的意义上讲，我把它从剧本搬上了电视。
General sense, for all of you letting it up here.
宏观地讲，献给在座的各位。
You know, I'm sure you've talked about how the week works.
你知道的，我确信你们讨论过一周的工作流程是怎样的。
You know, you read it, you have a production meeting, you know, whatever, we rehearse it and we fine tune it, we show it to everybody.
你知道的，你阅读剧本，开制作会议，你知道的，无论如何，我们排练并进行微调，然后把它展示给所有人。
And then more than anything with the help of a spectacular AD, that team, we sit down and figure out how do we get all of this done in this amount of time, and we move things around, which is one of the trickiest parts.
然后，在一位出色的副导演和团队的帮助下，最重要的是，我们坐下来想办法在规定时间内完成所有这些工作，我们四处调整，这是最棘手的部分之一。
Yeah.
对。
And then we say action, and we, for me, as you know, always looking at my watch, as well as looking at the monitor, very aware of what the job is.
然后我们喊开始，而对我来说，正如你们所知，我总是看着手表，同时也看着监视器，对这项工作有着高度的觉知。
I can't at the end of the week say, oh, sorry, we didn't get all of that accomplished.
我不能在周末时说，哦，对不起，我们没能完成所有这些。
So I was very aware of the restraints of the schedule, but because we didn't have to worry about an audience and because we had such a great freedom to explore when we were allowed to talk to each other, to talk to cameras and to get everybody to be a part of it, to be able to say to a camera operator, here's what I'm thinking, what do you think?
所以我对时间的限制有着清醒的认识，但因为我们不必担心现场观众，而且因为我们拥有极大的自由去探索——当我们被允许互相交流、与摄像机对话、让每个人都参与进来时——能够对摄像师说，“我是这么想的，你觉得呢？”
Like that's a great, you don't get to do that on a normal show, there's no time.
这太棒了，你在一般的剧组里可没有这种待遇，根本没时间。
But there's somebody who's behind that camera who sees things in a certain way, I do too, but so do they, let's get their take on this.
但那个摄像机背后的人以某种方式看待事物，我也是，但他们也是，让我们听听他们的看法。
And we got to sort of empower everybody on that stage in the most profound way to me, to get everybody to step up and take ownership of what we're creating.
我们以一种对我来说极其深刻的方式，赋权给舞台上的每一个人，让每个人都挺身而出，对我们所创造的东西产生归属感。
So we get to do all of that.
所以我们得以做到这一切。
You get to check these, you know, crossing off, you know, giving you, giving you notes by the end of it.
你可以检查这些，你知道的，打勾，你知道的，最后给你提意见。
I was texting Jason from my chair because everybody had their phones.
我坐在椅子上给杰森发短信，因为每个人都有手机。
I was like, did you do this and this in?
我当时想：你把这个和那个拍进去了吗？
And you just see him look at him and go.
然后你就会看到他看着你，然后点头。
It was just so, it was just so magical.
这真是太神奇了，简直太神奇了。
But get it done and we got it done, we got it done.
总之就是搞定它，我们做到了，我们搞定了。
You know, in grad school, I worked with a wonderful director named Ken Washington.
你知道，在研究生院时，我和一位名叫肯·华盛顿的优秀导演合作过。
And he told me that when he was younger, as a director, he thought all the good ideas had to come from him or they didn't count.
他告诉我，他年轻时作为一名导演，认为所有好的创意都必须来自他自己，否则就不算数。
And as he got older, he realized good ideas can come from anywhere.
而随着年龄增长，他意识到好的创意可以来自任何地方。
And they should come from anywhere.
并且它本就应该来自任何地方。
You're expanding your pallet so much more if you ask the camera op, what do you think is the best way to get this shot, but it also to take the architecture metaphor, it feels like Carter and Craig and the writing staff hand you a blueprint, right?
如果你问摄像师觉得用什么方式拍这个镜头最好，你的创作视野就会极大地拓宽，但这也让我想起建筑学的比喻——感觉卡特、克莱尔和编剧团队交给你一份蓝纸，对吧？
and you're on some level, tell me if you agree with this or not, like a bit of the contractor, like you have to figure out how to build the building from the thing they gave you.
从某种程度上来说——告诉我你是否同意这一点——你有点像个总承包商，你必须想办法根据他们给你的东西把这栋建筑建造起来。
They give you the specs, they give you, you know, and you have to figure out how do we bring this into form?
他们给你规格说明，他们给你，你知道的，而你必须弄清楚我们如何把这个具象化？
How do we bring this into reality?
我们如何把它变成现实？
Does that resonate?
这有共鸣吗？
It does, but the beauty is that the architects don't go away and that every day we're meeting.
有的，但美妙之处在于建筑师并没有走开，我们每天都在开会。
So that when I put something up and show it to them, we can tweak it.
所以当我把某个东西摆出来展示给他们看时，我们可以对它进行调整。
And because it's like detective work really, They've written this script upstairs.
因为这真的很像侦探工作。他们在楼上写了这个剧本。
We haven't seen it because we're working on something else.
我们没看过，因为我们在忙别的事。
And we get it and all of a sudden we're like, okay, here's what I think you mean.
我们拿到手，然后突然之间我们就会想，好吧，我觉得你们的意思是这样的。
Here's what I think will tell the story.
我觉得这样拍能讲好这个故事。
And then the beauty is I get to do that in turn around and go, guys, what do you think?
然后美妙之处就在于，我转过头去问：“伙计们，你们觉得呢？”
Is this, are we on the same page?
“这个行吗，我们的想法一致吗？”
And most of the time we work, but sometimes they were like, how about this?
大部分时候我们配合得很好，但有时他们会说：“这样怎么样？”
And again, collaboration, collaboration.
再说一次，这就是合作，这就是协作。
Yeah, it was so clever.
是的，太聪明了。
All the writers felt that way, Pam.
所有编剧都这么觉得，帕姆。
And I don't think that's necessarily how writers always feel about directors.
而且我觉得这未必是编剧对导演的一贯看法。
If I may be so bold, like, you were just so welcoming and open to trying stuff.
如果我可以斗胆直说的话，就是，你当时是如此热情欢迎并且愿意尝试各种新东西。
And we could, we would sit, you would have the writers sit right around you and just watch, and watch takes.
我们可以，我们可以坐着，你会让编剧们坐在你身边，看着，看着拍摄镜头。
And there's either that quad split, the four shots, four different cameras on a big TV screen.
大电视屏幕上要么是那种四分画面，四个镜头，四个不同的摄像机。
And you would.
而你就会。
You would turn to us and say, what do you think?
你就会转向我们说，你们觉得怎么样？
Or if we had a pitch, you'd say, let's give that a try.
或者如果我们有什么想法，你会说，我们试一试吧。
And then when you would go in and try and it wouldn't work, you wouldn't make us feel like assholes or anything.
然后当你们进去尝试却行不通的时候，你也不会让我们觉得自己像个白痴什么的。
You'd be like, all right, we tried that.
你会说，好吧，我们试过了。
But that's enough.
但这就够了。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
And if it did work, you'd be like, that's great and also this other idea.
如果真的行得通，你就会说，太棒了，还有另外这个想法。
And it was so safe of a creative space.
这是一个极具安全感的创作空间。
We talk about this a lot on the podcast.
我们在播客里经常讨论这个。
I just don't believe in fear leading to good work.
我就是不相信恐惧能带来好作品。
And there's this funny misconception, I think, in a lot of endeavors of all different shades and corporate, artistic, whatever.
我认为在许多不同领域的各种事务中，无论是企业、艺术还是其他什么，都有这样一个有趣的误区。
And I think this is the tone you set on stage when we're creating something is proof positive that people feel valued and safe to pitch things and safe to try things.
我认为这就是你在片场我们创作时定下的基调，它绝对是强有力的证明，让大家觉得自己的价值被认可，可以安全地提出想法，安全地去尝试。
And everyone's idea could get on and could be the best idea.
每个人的想法都可能被采纳，并成为最好的点子。
It doesn't matter who.
是谁提出的并不重要。
That's a really wonderful thing.
这真的是一件很棒的事。
And that was really important as young writers who had not run their own TV show to feel with the director.
作为尚未独立制作过自己电视剧的年轻编剧，能从导演身上感受到这一点，真的非常重要。
I don't know what we would have done if after that pilot you were like, I've got to go take these other 175 offers I have and left us.
我不知道如果拍完那集试播集之后，你就说“我得去接手我手头另外175个邀约了”然后抛下我们会怎么样。
And we'd had to sort of figure it out week to week with other directors and maybe not had that same dynamic, and the cast wouldn't have had that same feeling of safety and playfulness and curiosity.
那我们就得每周跟不同的导演去摸索，可能就不会有那种默契，演员们也不会有那种安全感、趣味性和好奇心。
I think it's a different show.
我觉得那会是另一部剧了。
I just think it's a completely different show.
我只是觉得那是完全不同的一部剧。
Yeah, but don't forget that you all made me better.
对，但别忘了，是你们所有人让我变得更好。
You pushed me, it wasn't one-sided.
你们鞭策了我，这不是单方面的。
I mean, I- I don't want to fight about this camp.
我是说，我——我不想为这个争论，伙计。
It's you, it's all you.
全靠你，全都是因为你。
After all these years.
历经这么多年。
You did.
你确实做了。
You pushed me.
你鞭策了我。
You made me better.
你让我变得更好。
You forced me into uncomfortable situations and I had to figure them out.
你把我逼进不舒服的境地，而我必须去解决它们。
There was a lot of painting ourselves in the corners wasn't there.
有很多把自己逼入绝境的情况，不是吗。
There was a lot of like, how do we get out of this one?
有很多类似这样的情况：我们怎么摆脱这个困境？
Well, it's a there's a great quote from some sculptor says, your life must be you have to ask yourself a question that you spend your whole life trying to figure out.
嗯，某个雕塑家有一句很棒的名言，他说，你的人生必须是，你必须问自己一个问题，然后花一辈子去试图弄明白它。
And the only caveat is you must never be able to figure it out.
唯一的条件是，你绝对不能把它弄明白。
Like, There's something about an insoluble question or unsolvable question that it's like as artists, like if something's too easy, it's almost like a difficulty of a puzzle or something like if it's too easy, it's not fun.
就像，某种关于无法解答的问题或难以解决的问题，作为艺术家，如果某件事太简单了，就像拼图的难度一样，如果太简单了就不好玩了。
It doesn't engage us.
它无法吸引我们。
If it's too hard, it makes us give up.
如果太难了，又会让我们放弃。
But there's a certain level of difficulty that I think is artists like we want and we need because it's enough of a pressure cooker that it pushes you towards innovation and outside the box thinking and that we constantly had to do that, you know?
但我觉得作为艺术家，我们需要并渴望某种程度的难度，因为它形成了一种足够的压力锅效应，能推动你走向创新和跳出框架的思考，而我们必须不断地这样做，你知道吗？
I also think vis-a-vis, I wanted to say, having guest directors, like, the culture on stage 22 was very particular.
我还想顺便说一下，关于邀请客座导演，22号摄影棚的文化非常独特。
It was, there was a very particular tone that I think we, we just created this thing and some guest stars just got it immediately and what waltz in and, and, and, you know, I think we actually, it was hard on some level to guest star but we also made it pretty homey and fun for people to guest star.
那种基调非常特别，我觉得我们，我们只是创造了这个东西，有些客座明星马上就能理解，然后走进来，然后，你知道的，我觉得客座出演在某种程度上其实挺不容易的，但我们也为客座演出的大家营造了非常温馨有趣的氛围。
but I think it would have been really hard to have had someone at the helm constantly changing.
但如果掌舵的人总是换来换去，那真的会非常难。
So I'm just echoing what Craig said that it was so wonderful for the show to have your steadiness and your presence was so, your reliable, theirness was everything.
所以我只是在呼应克雷格的话，剧组能有你的沉稳和陪伴真的是太棒了，你那种可靠的、“一直在”的姿态就是一切。
We love you, Pam.
我们爱你，帕姆。
That's the theme of this episode.
这就是这一集的主题。
Here's how much we love you.
这就是我们有多爱你。
We're not even gonna talk about Mary the paralegal at all because we can't stop talking about how much we love you.
我们甚至根本不会去谈论律师助理玛丽，因为我们一直在表达对你的爱，停不下来。
And the last thing I'll point out before we should pivot episode for these 10 minutes is that Pam left, I think you left two and a half men to come work with us, right?
在我把话题转开这最后10分钟之前，我想指出的最后一件事是，帕姆离开——我想你当时离开《好汉两个半》来跟我们合作，对吧？
Did you run the show two and a half men that was by far the number one comedy?
你当时是《好汉两个半》的导演吗？那可是绝对排名第一的喜剧。
I think you were the main director on that.
我想你是那部剧的主要导演。
She left the number one comedy number highest rated comedy on TV to come on to this weird experimental show written by two 30 year olds with a cast of a bunch of new newbies like Josh was a newer TV coach.
她离开了电视上收视率第一、排名第一的喜剧，来加入这个奇怪的、实验性的剧集。它由两个30岁的小伙子编写，演员阵容里有一群新人，比如乔施当时是个比较新的电视演员。
Just the leap of faith that you took there, God best best decision best decision two things one one for me and then one from someone I think Josh might want to Introduce because it goes right to everything that we've been saying here Pam I so I interviewed you Pam for the old version of this podcast and Something you said to me then has echoed any time I've been on set and it's so much of what Craig and Josh have been talking about I asked you we were talking about process of directing same question Josh had what do you do?
你当时迈出这一步需要多大的勇气啊。上帝啊，这是最棒的决定，绝对是最棒的决定。有两件事：第一件事是我的，然后第二件事我想乔施可能想介绍一下，因为它直接切中了我们在这里一直谈论的一切。帕姆，我以前为这个播客的旧版本采访过你，当时你对我说的话，每当我在片场时都会在脑海中回响，这正是克雷格和乔施一直在谈论的很多内容。我当时问你，我们在谈论导演的过程，和乔施问的同一个问题：你是怎么做的？
And I said, well, what's the most important part for you?
我说，那对你来说最重要的是什么？
And you said, making sure that everyone's enjoying themselves, which is that was not taught to me in director school.
你说，确保每个人都过得开心。这可不是在导演学校里教给我的。
We didn't pause for a week and talk about everyone should be happy and having fun.
我们没有停课一周，专门讨论每个人都应该开心和玩得高兴。
And that of all the choices of character development, story development, schedule, budget, that was quickly your answer was clear and is clear from this discussion and has affected me very much.
在所有关于角色发展、故事发展、日程安排、预算的选择中，你的答案脱口而出，从这次讨论中也能听得很清楚，它深深地影响了我。
So I thank you for it.
所以我为此感谢你。
but also just to tell the guys, this is her answer.
但我也想告诉大家，这就是她的答案。
This is what she was there for.
这就是她在那里的原因。
You know, I will just tell you that it come because I had done it for a while before that, not all sense are like this, not all sense are warm and fuzzy and all of that.
你知道，我只想告诉你，因为我之前已经干了一段时间了，并不是所有的片场都像这样，不是所有的片场都是温暖融洽之类什么的。
And to be able to make that the mandate on stage 22.
而能够把这一点作为22号摄影棚的铁律。
This is the nicest place you're ever gonna work.
这是你工作过的最棒的地方。
We're gonna work hard, but we're gonna love each other and respect each other, to be able to create that.
我们会努力工作，但我们会彼此相爱、彼此尊重，能够创造出这样的环境。
I mean, that's why you stay for nine years.
我的意思是，这就是你一待就是九年的原因。
I hope you're listening, young directors of the next generation, because we want more like that.
我希望你们这些新一代的年轻导演正在听，因为我们需要更多这样的人。
This brings us up to a recurring segment on the show that we like to call.
这就把我们带到了节目中的一个固定环节，我们喜欢称之为：
Questions and observations from a clinical psychologist who's never seen how I met your mother and also happens to be married to Josh.
来自一位从未看过《老爸老妈浪漫史》、同时恰好也是乔施的妻子的临床心理学家的疑问与观察。
Hi, Pam.
嗨，帕姆。
I know we haven't had much time to connect in person, but I've heard so much about you.
我知道我们没有太多时间面对面交流，但我已经听过太多关于你的事了。
And the thing I've maybe heard most frequently was that on the set of how I met your mother, you were the mother, that you were nurturing, that you were always working to make people feel safe and helping them live up to their artistic potential.
我听到最多的可能就是，在《老爸老妈浪漫史》的片场，你就像妈妈一样，你充满了关爱，你总是努力让人们感到安全，并帮助他们发挥出艺术上的全部潜能。
So I was wondering if you could talk about that more specifically.
所以我很好奇你能否更具体地谈谈这一点。
If you were conscious of playing this archetype, or if it was just intuitive for you, if you fall into this role on other sets or if it felt like you were particularly pulled into it on him for some reason.
你是刻意在扮演这个原型，还是这只是出于你的直觉？你在其他片场也会落入这个角色，还是觉得出于某种原因，你特别被吸引到了《老爸老妈浪漫史》的这个角色中？
And then lastly, if you feel comfortable sharing, what were some of the unique ways you may have connected with or mothered in a certain way, Josh and Craig, or maybe some of the other actors on set who you needed your support in order to live up to their potential on this show?
最后，如果你觉得方便分享的话，你曾用什么独特的方式与乔施和克雷格，或者片场其他可能需要你的支持才能在这部剧里发挥潜力的演员进行交流或给予他们母亲般的关怀？
my God, why is she so smart?
天哪，她为什么这么聪明？
She's so smart.
她太聪明了。
She's just so smart.
她就是这么聪明。
Now you're doing it to Jordana.
现在你对乔丹娜也这样了。
You're doing it to Jordana now.
你现在对乔丹娜也这样。
You're being that person.
你正在扮演那个人。
You're so nurturing towards my wife and her question.
你对我妻子和她的问题表现得太有母性的关怀了。
It's true.
确实如此。
I mean, by the way, this is me.
我的意思是，顺便说一句，这就是我。
This is, you know, yes, intuitive, of treat people the way you want to be treated, just really simple stuff.
这就是，你知道的，是的，出于直觉，己所不欲，勿施于人，只是一些非常简单的道理。
I can't, I can't exactly put it into words.
我无法，我无法准确地用言语表达出来。
I just, I appreciate the opportunity of getting to mother people.
我只是，我很感激有照顾别人的机会。
I see, I think, what they may need and not only can they get things from me, but in that process I'm getting something back.
我想我能看出他们可能需要什么，不仅他们能从我这里得到东西，而且在这个过程中我也在得到回报。
And this particular place with these particular people made it so easy and so fulfilling.
而这个特定地方和这些特定的人让这一切变得如此简单，如此充实。
And I do, obviously, I myself on every set, but there are so many times when there are other layers, because I'm obviously not working in a vacuum, lots of producers, lots of, you know, that prevent me from being my true self, you know, I'm not the final word on everything.
当然，我在每个片场都会做我自己，但很多时候还有其他层面的影响，因为我显然不是在真空中工作，有很多制片人，有很多，你知道的，这些阻碍了我展现真实的自我，你知道的，我并不是对所有事情都有最终决定权。
But on this particular show, everybody, and it stops with Carter and Craig, all these people had the biggest hearts and were compassionate, and smart, and wise, and creative, and all of those crazy, ridiculous, wonderful adjectives.
但在这部特殊的剧中，每个人——从卡特和克雷格开始，所有人都有着最博大的胸怀，充满同情心、聪明、睿智、极具创造力，还有所有那些疯狂、荒谬、美妙的形容词。
So it made it all, it was the perfect storm of wonderful.
所以这一切促成了它，这是一场美妙的完美风暴。
It was the perfect storm of wonderful.
这是一场美妙的完美风暴。
It also strikes me, though, that you were, since you were there at the beginning, you got to help set the tone.
不过，我也觉得，既然你从一开始就在那里，你得以帮助确立了基调。
You weren't brought into a functioning factory of something that already had its own culture.
你不是被带到一个已经有一套自己的文化的成熟运转的工厂里。
You were asked to help institute and create the culture.
你是被邀请去帮助建立和创造这种文化。
So it's almost like they say, if you don't like kids, it's like, well, you'll like your own kids.
所以这有点像人们常说的，如果你不喜欢小孩子，就会有人说，嗯，你会喜欢你自己的孩子。
When you raise your own kids, they have a different quality to you.
当你抚养你自己的孩子时，他们对你来说会有着不同的意义。
This show was your kids.
这部剧就是你的孩子。
We were your kids.
我们曾经是你们的孩子。
And I, by the way, I still kind of feel that way.
顺便说一句，我其实现在还是有这种感觉。
Kind of, kind of stuff.
有点，有点那种感觉。
Yeah.
对。
Very proud.
非常骄傲。
I'm very proud of my kids.
我为我的孩子们感到非常骄傲。
Thank you.
谢谢。
How lucky are we to be?
我们能成为这样的人是多么幸运？
I really am.
我真的是这么觉得。
我真的是。
Are we really not going to talk about this?
我们真的不打算聊聊这个吗？
Yeah.
对。
I feel like we have to.
我觉得我们不得不聊。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
Let's, let's back.
我们，我们倒回一点。
Did you watch it?
你看了吗？
It's a panel on re-watching.
这是一个关于重温的座谈会。
I absolutely.
我绝对看了。
Sandy Rivers.
桑迪·里弗斯。
Come on.
拜托。
How did it feel to you re-watching it 20 years later?
在20年后再看，你有什么感觉？
19 I mean, it just, I mean, it looks that way, it looks that way, it was fantastic for me getting that.
19年，我的意思是，它就是那样，看起来就是那样，对我来说能得到那个角色真是太棒了。
When I say that everyone, they would laugh, the crew would laugh once and then stop.
每当我对大家这么说时，他们会笑，剧组会笑一次然后就停下来。
Not for looks that way, looks that way.
不是那种“看起来就是那样、看起来就是那样”的意思。
It killed at the table reed, it killed at the run through, it killed at the rehearsal, and it killed when he did it.
它在台本围读时笑翻全场，在串场时笑翻全场，在排练时笑翻全场，他演的时候也笑翻全场。
We missed not doing a spin off of Sandy Rivers, by the way, that was one of our, there's not too many regrets, but how much fun was Alexa's Dennis off having and with his you know, it was funny to there's that moment where there were Lily kind of snaps at him, Lily, who has been deprived of her nap time at school.
顺便说一句，我们错过了没有拍一部关于桑迪·里弗斯的衍生剧，那是我们——遗憾其实不多，但亚历克斯·丹尼斯（Alexa's Dennis）当时玩得有多开心啊，还有他和那个……你知道的，有个场景很有趣，莉莉有点对她发脾气了，莉莉在学校里被剥夺了午睡时间。
It was also her nap, not just the kindergarten, there's nap time, her nap time.
这也是她的午睡，不仅仅是幼儿园的午睡时间，是她的午睡时间。
She snaps at Alexa's and it's so fun.
她对亚历克斯发脾气，这太有趣了。
It just is a married couple.
这感觉就像是一对已婚夫妇。
That's their first interaction like other than I'm like Buffy and Angel and she just basically just tells him to shut the to fuck up.
那是他们除了……我感觉就像巴菲和天使（Buffy and Angel），她基本上就是让他闭上他妈的嘴。
And there's something that I just laughed so hard, just like that's their inaugural Hemium interaction.
有一点让我笑得前仰后合，就像那是他们婚姻生活的首次互动。
And everything in his hair just all good hair.
而且他头发里的所有东西看起来都发质很好。
This is so dumb to say about actors.
对演员说这种话显得太蠢了。
But I was watching it and I was like, Lily and Sandy Rivers look like they don't know each other.
但我看的时候就在想，莉莉和桑迪·里弗斯看起来就像互不相识一样。
I know they're playing characters, but they're married.
我知道他们在演角色，但他们是夫妻。
They're married people and they were just like doing such good acting.
他们是已婚人士，而且他们只是演得太好了。
Oh, they're good actors.
哦，他们是好演员。
They're good actors.
他们是优秀的演员。
Yeah.
对。
There was more product in his hair.
他头发里用了更多定型产品。
I just remember going into hair and makeup and it It just was, it was just fantastic.
我只记得去化妆间的时候，那感觉，真是太棒了。
Marshall Heading's, I've been hiding small items in his hair all night, really surprised.
马歇尔·海丁斯，我整晚都在他头发里藏小物件，真的很惊讶。
I really forgot that he had been hiding.
我真的忘了他在里面藏了东西。
And then I remember there was going to be that payoff.
然后我记得会有那个揭晓的时刻。
And you have to wait a while to get to the payoff.
你得等上一会儿才能看到结果。
And when he turns and leaves, there's a little coffee that goes worth it.
当他转身离开时，掉出了一小杯咖啡，太值了。
So Alec, when did this episode air?
所以，亚历克，这一集是什么时候播出的？
What was the air date of this episode?
这一集的播出日期是什么时候？
April 24th, 2006.
2006年4月24日。
Ah, coming up on May sweeps when that used to be a thing.
啊，即将迎来五月的收视率大战，虽然现在这个概念已经不常见了。
All of those telepathic conversations.
所有那些心灵感应般的对话。
Wait, Craig, real quick, just tell, just tell our listeners what, uh, what this episode's about.
等等，克雷格，简单说一下，跟我们的听众讲讲，呃，这一集到底是关于什么的。
Just can you summarize it real quick for people?
你能简短给大伙总结一下吗？
Just to.
就是为了。
Right.
对。
Yeah.
对啊。
So the, this is Robin has been nominated for a local area media media award or a llama.
所以，这一集是罗宾被提名了一个地方媒体奖（LLAMA）。
And the whole gang is going to go there.
然后一帮人都要去现场。
She is taking her, her, her fellow newscaster, Sandy Rivers, who's this incredibly cheesy news games, this like very full of himself, even though he's on this crappy little channel.
她带着她的同行新闻主播桑迪·里弗斯，这家伙油腔滑调的，新闻水平挺逗，自我感觉极其良好，尽管他只是在一个烂透了的小频道工作。
Robin is taking him as her date, and it makes Ted want to take a date to because Robin and Ted are on the outs, and each wants to make the other jealous.
罗宾带他作为自己的女伴，这让泰德也想带个女伴去，因为罗宾和泰德当时正处於冷战期，双方都想让对方吃醋。
And Barney says, well, you should take a paid escort.
然后巴尼说，那你应该雇个付费陪同。
And Ted says, no, and Barney brings delivers such said paid escort to Ted anyway.
泰德说不，结果巴尼还是把这个所谓的付费陪同送到了泰德身边。
And of course, the big twist that happens to live in his building.
当然，最大的反转是她刚好住在他的大楼里。
Who happens to live in his building?
谁刚好住在他的大楼里？
And at the end, she was not actually that.
最后，其实她根本不是那样的。
Barney was just completely fucking with Ted the whole time, and hilarity ensues.
巴尼从头到尾只是在狠狠地耍泰德，然后各种爆笑情节随之而来。
But there is this emotional through-line of Robin and Ted that sort of gives us suspense and tension through the whole episode.
但罗宾和泰德之间有一条情感主线，为整集提供了悬念和张力。
Yeah, it's a kind of light funny one in other other ways.
对，在其他方面这是一集比较轻松搞笑的内容。
We've been talking, Pam, about the hotel door.
帕姆，我们之前一直在聊那个酒店的门。
I don't remember shooting that so well.
我不记得当时那场戏拍得有多好了。
But we've been talking about the kind of thing that Carter and Craig and the writers had to do a lot, which was you would have these episodes that had a comic conceit at the center of them.
但我们一直在讨论卡特、克雷格和编剧们经常需要做的一种事情，那就是你会拍一些核心带有某种喜剧构思的剧集。
The comic conceit is that Ted thinks he's on a date with a prostitute and it turns out he's not.
这个喜剧构思就是泰德以为自己跟一个妓女约会，结果发现并不是。
I mean, that's the kind of core comedy engine, but it furthers the emotional kind of drama of Ted and Robin and them kind of using these dates to kind of dig at each other.
我的意思是，这是核心的喜剧引擎，但它推动了泰德和罗宾的情感戏剧，以及他们如何利用这些约会来互相刺激。
And it's pretty devastating Robin's thanking her friends at the awards podium and not thanking Ted.
罗宾在领奖台上感谢她的朋友们却没有感谢泰德，这真的挺让人心碎的。
It moves the plot down the the field, but it also is a standalone episode in its own way.
它推动了剧情发展，但从某种程度上来说，它也是一集相对独立的剧集。
Absolutely.
确实如此。
I mean, so character driven though, so character, you learn so much.
我是说，太注重角色了，通过角色，你能学到很多。
It's hard to shoot.
这很难拍。
So that was that's also not your typical how much mother episode where they were all together at this huge set, right?
所以这也是一部不太典型的《老爸老妈浪漫史》剧集，他们不是全都聚在一个巨大的布景里，对吧？
We built this huge kind of banquet hall set with a stage and all of these weird extras and it's like the local area, TV celebrities, including this weird vampire guy who's based I think a guy named Superhost that used to host a local TV show in Cleveland when Carter was growing up.
我们搭建了一个巨大的宴会厅布景，有舞台和各种奇怪的群众演员，就像地方电视台的名人一样，包括一个奇怪的吸 vampires 类型的家伙，我想他是以一个叫超级主持人的家伙为原型的，卡特小时候在克利夫兰时，那个人经常主持当地的一个电视节目。
So that's Carter loved getting to sort of do a version of this weird, like beloved local TV personality from Cleveland.
所以卡特很喜欢做这样一个来自克利夫兰的、奇怪且备受喜爱的地方电视主持人的版本。
And so what was it like, how do you hold on to the energy?
那么，感觉怎么样，你是如何保持精力的？
Because shooting in one big place for a lot of the episode, I found that hard to do, hard to write anyway, hard to write.
因为在剧集的大部分时间里都在一个大地方拍摄，我发现这很难做到，写起来也很难，总之很难写。
And you're like moving the people around this big shared space.
而且你要让演员们在这个巨大的共享空间里移动。
That was one of the first times we did an episode like that, right?
那是我们第一次拍这样的剧集，对吧？
All in one huge set and obviously we pop around a bit, but it goes back to what we were talking about earlier, which is there was no, there couldn't be an audience because you couldn't, you couldn't shoot something like that.
全在一个巨大的布景里，当然我们也会转场几次，但这回到了我们之前讨论过的话题，那就是现场没有、也不可能有现场观众，因为你根本无法拍摄那种场面的东西。
Yeah.
对。
Because that ate up half the stage.
因为那占用了舞台的一半空间。
Right.
没错。
Well, you know, so we got to do it a little differently, a little better.
好吧，你知道的，所以我们得用稍微不同的、稍微更好的方式来拍。
And Josh will tell you, I just, as soon as we started rolling, I'd yell, energy, because It is an energy diffuses in those huge sets, yeah.
乔什会告诉你，我一开机就会大喊：“拿出活力来！”因为在那些巨大的布景里，活力是会消散的，是的。
Every take is the first take, you know?
每一个镜头都当成第一个镜头来拍，你知道吗？
I mean, you really have to perform.
我是说，你必须全力以赴地表演。
And then people don't understand is like the X, there's 50 or I don't know how many extras are just milling about.
然后人们不理解的是，比如群众演员，有50个或者我不知道有多少个群演就在那里闲逛。
And they're miming and talking, but not making noise.
他们假装在做动作和聊天，但不出声音。
Like it's really, it's a strange thing, you know?
就真的很奇怪，你知道吗？
And then the mics are over the main characters trying to get the, I don't think people understand how set culture is a whole different thing.
然后麦克风放在主要角色上方，试图收音，我觉得人们并不了解片场文化完全是另一回事。
One thing that I was struck with, I was thinking about vampire Lou and Korean Elvis and Sandy Rivers.
我有一个深刻的感悟，我在想吸血鬼路、韩国猫王和桑迪·里弗斯。
And I wonder, Craig, if you guys, it felt like, cause I've been watching some old Simpsons, like it felt like how the Simpsons populates the town with these second and third kind of tier characters, like Disco Stu and Mo and Barney and like all, you know what I'm saying?
我在想，克雷格，你们这些人，感觉就像——因为我一直在看一些老《辛普森一家》，感觉就像《辛普森一家》里那些第二、第三梯队的次要角色，比如迪斯科·斯图、莫、巴尼，还有所有人，你知道我在说什么吗？
Like you populate the town.
就像你们让这座城市充满了生机。
And I felt like you guys did a really great job at creating these characters who were not part of the main five gang, but you could go back to the well, Ranjit being a great example.
我觉得你们在塑造这些角色方面做得非常出色，他们虽然不是五人主角团的成员，但你们可以反复挖掘，兰吉特就是一个很好的例子。
Cause it's, it made, we talked about it, made New York feel like this small magical town, even though it's one of the biggest cities in the world.
因为我们讨论过，这让纽约感觉像是一个充满魔法的小镇，尽管它是世界上最大的城市之一。
I love the moments we got to do that because I think Robin's job gave you a lot of that.
我很喜欢我们能做到这一点的时刻，因为我觉得罗宾的工作给你们提供了很多这样的机会。
Like Robin's, the lens on New York through like the small town news that is, Like there really is a new, it's basically New York one, right?
就像罗宾通过类似小镇新闻的视角来看待纽约，就像真的有一个新闻频道，基本上就是纽约一台，对吧？
It's New York one in New York.
这就是纽约的纽约一台。
And there really was a guy on there who he was not like Sandy Rivers, but he would read the headlines from the newspaper as one of the morning segments on the show.
那里真的有一个人，他虽然不像桑迪·里弗斯，但他会在节目的早间板块中宣读报纸上的头条新闻。
He may still be doing it.
他现在可能还在这么做。
He's definitely still on New York one because they seem to have this guy Pat Kiernan.
他绝对还在纽约一台，因为他们似乎有帕特·基尔南这个人。
I kind of love him.
我挺喜欢他的。
He's great.
他很棒。
He's in New York celebrity.
他是纽约的名人。
And just the, it feels like a small town at times, New York.
有时候纽约真的感觉像个小镇。
It really does and like people in subway ads and like local TV ads and stuff.
确实如此，比如地铁广告里的人、当地电视广告里的人之类的。
I think the world has lost so much of that as the world gets more digital and stuff, but you were, it's a small town, right?
随着世界变得越来越数字化，我认为世界已经失去了很多那种感觉，但你曾经说过，它是个小镇，对吧？
Your little slice of New York is your own little small town.
你那一小片纽约就是你自己的小镇。
And I think, yeah, I think this episode had some of that in it, I love that feeling.
而且我觉得，是的，我觉得这一集里也有一些那种感觉，我很喜欢那种感觉。
Yeah, I might have said this last episode, but was it anything good happens after two a.m.
对，我可能在上一集说过这个，但在“凌晨两点之后不会发生什么好事”那一集里，桑迪向罗宾求爱并说做爱很有趣。
where Sandy propositions Robin and says, having sex is fun.
你知道那是什么吗？
Do you know what was that?
我想那是在里面，对，对。
I think that was in though, yeah, yeah.
但我只想重申，亚历克西斯·丹尼斯索夫，我不知道他是怎么做到的。
But I think I just want to repeat that Alexis Dennisoff, I don't know how he does this.
而且我认为这有点像演员的魔术。
and I think it's kind of an actor magic trick.
He is playing a buffoonish, broad, broadly drawn character with deep and impressive subtlety.
他在扮演一个滑稽、脸谱化、粗线条的人物，却展现出了深沉而令人印象深刻的细腻感。
Like he's doing two things at once that are, it makes it so much funnier because you kind of feel like this could be an actual human.
就像他在同时做两件事，这让它变得更有趣，因为你会觉得这可能是一个真实的活人。
This would be a ridiculous human, but I believe that this is a human being, you know, who made some choices somewhere along the way that got him to be Sandy Rivers.
这会是一个荒谬的人，但我相信这是一个真正的人，你知道的，他在人生某个阶段做出了一些选择，才让他成为了桑迪·里弗斯。
You know, that's not his real name, you know, but just shout out to Alexis such an incredible performance.
你知道，那不是他的真名，但还是要向亚历克斯致敬，这是如此不可思议的表演。
And a shout out to is Chris Harris, right?
还要向克里斯·哈里斯致敬，对吧？
This is a Chris Harris show.
这是一个克里斯·哈里斯的节目。
Yeah, Chris Harris is one of the all-time and great hymnum writers wrote this one.
是的，克里斯·哈里斯是有史以来最伟大的赞美诗/编剧之一，他写了这一集。
I guess this is third one of season one.
我想这是第一季的第三集。
And yeah, and it's the introduction of Marshall Singh lawyer, which we did a hundred more times in nine seasons.
是的，这也是马修·辛（Marshall Singh）律师的登场，我们在九季里把这个梗拍了一百多次。
Lawyer, it's the introduction of telepathy.
律师，这是心灵感应的引入。
The characters speaking through telepathy.
角色通过心灵感应说话。
It's the first time we did that.
这是我们第一次这样做。
One of the, I love that bit.
其中一个，我非常喜欢那个桥段。
And I love the magical realism that it really works at one point in this episode.
我喜欢这种魔幻现实主义，在这一集里它真的起作用了。
Like Lily really hears it and she says, she's a prostitute.
比如莉莉真的听到了，她说，她是个妓女。
That was like, I love the sort of like absolute supernatural.
那感觉就像，我喜欢这种绝对的超自然现象。
She really can hear Marshall's thoughts.
她真的能听到马修的想法。
Yeah, I love how many sort of first things.
是的，我喜欢这里有多少个“第一次”。
I do want to say there is one thing in here I really didn't like.
我确实想说，这里有一件事我真的很不喜欢。
I just want to say it because we're kind of owning some things and there's a moment in here where Barney makes reference to like a prostitute where he uses a disparaging word for the trans community that I think 20 years ago, we were too young and ignorant to realize you should not say.
我只是想把它说出来，因为我们在正视一些事情，这里有一个时刻，巴尼提到了一个类似妓女的词，他用了一个对跨性别群体带有贬义的词，我认为20年前，我们太年轻、太无知，没意识到不应该说这个词。
And it is a show of love, it is a show of heart.
这是一部充满爱的剧，这是一部充满内涵的剧。
This was a rare moment where I think we got it wrong.
这是一个罕见的时刻，我认为我们做错了。
And I think like looking back 20 years later, it just feels important to own some of those moments.
我觉得20年后再回头看，正视其中的某些时刻显得尤为重要。
I think at the time it was like, oh, there's sort of a, it's like a comedy thing.
我想当时大家的态度是，哦，这有点像，这就像是一个喜剧梗。
You can say it, no, it's not a good comedy where it's not an acceptable thing to say.
你可以说，不，这不是一个好笑的喜剧，这不是一个可以接受的说法。
And I wanted to especially say it because of our beautiful opening message from that, how I met your mother, a fan who said he feels so seen, he has autism, he has cerebral palsy, he's a person living with those challenges.
我想特别提一下这件事，因为我们收到了来自《老爸老妈浪漫史》粉丝的一条美妙的开场留言，他说他感到了被看见，他有自闭症，有脑瘫，是一个正在经历这些挑战的人。
I became a parent of a kid with a disability between year two and year three of how much your mother, Pam, many deep talks were had, many talk about Pam knowing what people need and getting people through the hard times to still do the work, you were that for me, very much in that moment.
在《老爸老妈浪漫史》第二年到第三年之间，我成了一个残疾孩子的家长，帕姆，我们有过很多次深度的交谈，谈到帕姆懂得人们需要什么，帮助大家度过艰难时期并继续坚持工作，在那一刻，你对我也正是如此。
And just the way that changed my perspective on using certain words as if they're okay, comedy words, the disability community has very strong opinions about that.
还有这种改变我观点的方式，关于使用某些词汇时觉得它们没问题，比如那些喜剧笑料里的词，残疾人群体对此有着非常强烈的看法。
And I've learned so much about that and looking back on how maybe in my 20s or being in comedy veterans rooms, words are thrown about.
我对此了解了很多，回想起我在二十多岁时，或者在老派喜剧编剧室里，那些随口抛出的词汇。
And it's just interesting, even in the show, that I'm so proud of and there's so much love in it that we could get something like that wrong and sort of not know any better.
这真的很有趣，甚至在这部我如此骄傲、充满爱意的剧中，我们竟然也会把这种事情搞错，可以说是有点不知者无畏了。
I'm really surprised.
我真的很惊讶。
There's not too many of them.
这样的地方其实不多。
But as we go through season one, we're almost done with season one.
但当我们回顾第一季时，我们马上就要看完第一季了。
There's a few of those moments where I go, boy, would I not say that.
有那么几个瞬间，我会想，天哪，我绝不会那样说。
that same way.
绝不会用那种方式。
I just feel like it was important to own to own that.
我只是觉得，正视并承认这一点很重要。
I think there will be more moments like that moving forward.
我想以后还会有更多这样的时刻。
But I think all you can do when you've made a mistake like that is own it.
但我觉得，当你犯了这样的错误时，你能做的就是承认它。
Say and just say sorry and just learn and try to do better and try to be more respectful.
说声抱歉，然后去学习，试着做得更好，试着更有同理心、更尊重他人。
So I just wanted to bring that up because it feels it feels weird to not say it.
所以我只是想把这件事提出来，因为如果不说的话感觉怪怪的。
It jumped out at me.
它一下子就跳出来抓住了我。
I love this episode.
我很喜欢这一集。
And again, no one in that writer's room is anything but an open warmhearted person.
再说一次，那个编剧室里的每一个人都是思想开放、内心温暖的人。
No one wanted to be throwing slurs around.
没有人想随口说出带有侮辱性的词汇。
But there it is.
但事实就是如此。
There is that wrong word in there and I just want to say I, you know, from all of us, I know Carter very, very much feels the same way.
那个错误的词就在那里，我只想说，我，你知道的，我们所有人都这样觉得，我知道卡特也绝对有同感。
I just are apologies for getting things like that wrong.
对于把事情搞砸成这样，我们深表歉意。
We didn't know better and we've learned.
我们当时并不懂，但我们已经吸取了教训。
It's like that Tony, I think it's Tony Morrison says, you know, when you know better, you do better.
就像托妮·莫里森说的，你知道得更多了，就能做得更好。
Like, you know, I think that's what this is about.
就像，你知道的，我觉得这就是这个意思。
So, you know, I, just to get back to the episode, I telepathy, when people ask me like, what What are some of your favorite, how I met your mother runners?
所以，你知道的，我，为了回到这一集上来，我讲讲心灵感应，当人们问我，比如说，《老爸老妈浪漫史》里你最喜欢的连贯桥段有哪些？
I love the intervention.
我特别喜欢干预。
Banner is so funny to me.
巴纳真的很搞笑。
But telepathy is, I don't know why it's so funny because one, I just love having to do the silent, it's like you have to be a silent film star in those moments.
但心灵感应，我不知道为什么它这么好笑，因为第一，我就是喜欢这种不得不保持沉默的感觉，在那些时刻你得像个默片演员一样。
Like you're doing some good eyebrow acting in this photo.
就像你在这场戏里做了一些很棒的眉毛演技。
I mean, I think like our stand-ins would read the lines, right?
我的意思是，我觉得好像是我们的替身演员来念台词，对吧？
And we would do just face acting.
然后我们只负责面部表演。
We would record you.
我们会录下你的声音。
We recorded you at the top of the scenes and we'll be playing it back, yeah.
我们在场景开始时录下了你的声音，然后回放出来，是的。
That's right, right.
对的，没错。
But there's also something so, I think the reason it's particularly funny is because when you become such dear friends with people when you become a tribe, you do, you have it, you have telepathy.
但其中也有一些很奇妙的东西，我想它特别搞笑的原因是，当你和人们成为如此亲密的朋友，当你形成一个小团体时，你确实会有，你们会有心灵感应。
I mean, you might get it wrong, you might not, but you do have so much unspoken between you and there's so much, there's so many furtive glances and I know what you're thinking or, you know, hitting under the table because you're both thinking the same thing.
我的意思是，你可能会猜错，也可能不会，但你们之间确实有太多无需言说的心领神会，有太多的暗送秋眸，我知道你在想什么，或者，你知道的，在桌子底下踢对方因为你们俩想的是同一件事。
So I just thought it was a great way to deepen and reveal their friendship more, you know, that they're, what do you say?
所以我只是觉得这是一个很好的方式，能够更深入地展现和揭示他们的友谊，你知道的，他们，你管这叫什么？
One of our famous, you know, that's very Gene Shepherd, right?
我们著名的，你知道的，那非常具有吉ーン·谢泼德的风格，对吧？
Our famous telepathic conversation.
我们著名的心灵感应对话。
Yes, yes, branding the thing and saying this is a historical document of this very famous thing we did recurring, yeah, because it's Ted's, it's future Ted's story in his life.
是的，是的，给这个桥段定性，说这是一个具有历史意义的桥段，是我们经常做的标志性桥段，对，因为这是泰德的，是未来泰德讲述他生活中的故事。
That's a famous known thing that his group would do.
这是他那群朋友会做的一件广为人知的事。
And it's, were those fun as dude Pam?
那些拍起来好玩吗，帕姆？
That's definitely something you were not probably shooting on other sitcoms.
这绝对是你平时在其他情景喜剧里拍不到的东西。
It's so weird.
太怪异了。
It was hilarious.
但搞笑极了。
And that's why I remember because we wouldn't record.
这就是为什么我印象深刻，因为我们不进行现场录音。
And then just to play it back and watch you.
然后只是把它放出来看着你。
Act to their your own voice.
对着你自己的声音演戏。
Yeah, Josh is acting to his read.
对，乔希是对着自己的配音在演戏。
So that's why it's so good.
所以这剧才这么棒。
Yeah.
对啊。
You know, I've heard from so many people and we've talked about this, but I'm now friends, like my friend, Nima, grew up in Tehran in Iran and he learned English from watching Scrubs and how I met your mother and friends.
你知道的，我从很多人那里听说过，我们之前也聊过这个，不过我现在有朋友了，比如我的朋友尼玛（Nima），他在伊朗德黑兰长大，他就是通过看《实习医生风云》（Scrubs）、《老爸老妈浪漫史》和《老友记》来学英语的。
Like that's how he learned to speak English.
他就是这样学会说英语的。
and I've heard it from so many people.
而且我从好多人那里都听过这种说法。
But I think it's also funny, as I watch this show, and I watch with, sometimes it'll occur to me, like, oh, this is teaching people English, and it's also teaching them some incredibly strange words.
但我觉得也挺有意思的，当我看着这部剧，一边看有时就会突然意识到，哦，这不仅是在教人们英语，还在教他们一些极其奇怪的词汇。
Like I thought about like, hacied, curdism, you know, kabron, I mean, they would know kabron.
就像我想到的，乡巴佬（hacied）、乡村气（curdism），你知道的，混蛋（kabron），我是说，他们肯定知道混蛋（kabron）。
But there's just so many funny words and turns of phrase that they'd be like, what is that?
但里面有太多有趣的词汇和措辞，让人不禁想问：那是什么意思？
Like, if you're like, like busting your apple bag.
比如，说什么“累死累活”（busting your apple bag）。
Yeah, yeah, busting your apple bag.
对啊，对啊，“累死累活”。
But if a non-English speaker said, oh, I learned the way word hay seed, I'm like, you're not gonna use that that much.
但如果一个非英语母语者说：“哦，我学会了‘乡巴佬’（hay seed）这个词，”我会想，你其实没多少机会用这个词。
Like, you don't have to keep that one in your back pocket.
不用把它当成杀手锏藏在口袋里。
But yeah, I mean, I loved the first time Marshall cues up for lawyering Barney.
不过说真的，我超喜欢马歇尔第一次为了巴尼准备大展身手法兰克林式辩护的场景。
There's something Jason would do, like his kind of like licking his lips and getting ready to lawyer someone was always so funny to me.
那是杰森会做的事，他那种舔舔嘴唇、准备好跟人打官司的样子，我一直觉得特别搞笑。
I loved one out of five, one out of six, one out of eight women in America is a prostitute.
我好喜欢“美国每五个、六个、八个女人里就有一个是妓女”。
It's very funny.
太逗了。
Bunch of naked dudes hanging brain.
一堆光屁股大老爷们在露阴。
He's made up like, I'd never heard that phrase before.
他编出来的，我以前从来没听过这个说法。
I said good day was so funny.
“代我问候一声”（I said good day）太搞笑了。
Yeah, he's just waiting to get out the second half of that.
对啊，他就是在等时机把后面那半句说出来。
It also struck me that Barney is always waiting for Ted's love plans to get foiled so that he can jump in with, so that he can pull him over to the dark side.
我还注意到，巴尼总是等着泰德的求爱计划泡汤，这样他就能趁虚而入，把他拉进黑暗势力。
So he delights in this thing that's going on, you know?
所以他乐于看到这种事情发生，对吧？
He also has a surprisingly expansive view in this one towards like presiduses against sex workers.
在这集里，他对性工作者的偏见也展现出了一种令人惊讶的广阔视角。
He's kind of like, even though this woman does not actually a prostitute in the end, Barney has a surprisingly progressive take- He mounts like a beautiful defensive, yeah.
他有点像……尽管这个女人到头来其实并不是个妓女，但巴尼持有一种出人意料的前卫态度——他做出了精彩的辩护，对。
Yeah, like kind of an evolved take and the right take.
对，可以说是种很成熟的观点，而且是正确的观点。
Yeah, court of sense of people, like come on, don't judge someone because of what they do.
对，要有常识，拜托，别因为别人的职业就去评判他们。
And of course, it's all the complete bullshit, but he's right, right?
当然，这完全是胡扯，但他说的没错，对吧？
I mean, if we're talking about being a little more expansive and progressive minded, Barney actually sort of weirdly espouses some of that in this episode.
我是说，如果我们谈论得更加包容和前卫一点，巴尼在这集里居然还真有点诡异地宣扬了这些观点。
I loved, use my full name, people get a kick out of it.
我超喜欢那句：“叫我全名，大家都很吃桑迪·里弗斯（Sandy Rivers）太搞笑了。
Sandy Rivers was so funny.
桑迪·里弗斯太搞笑了。
Hey, you think she's so fast?
嘿，你觉得她那么随便吗？
And you know what else?
你还知道吗？
The, when, when Aaron, who played Mary, who was so wonderful, shout out to Aaron.
当……当扮演玛丽的艾伦（Aaron）说出她当律师助理的那家律师事务所的名字时，玛丽真的太棒了，向艾伦致敬。
But when she says the name of the law firm that she's a paralegal at, and Marshall's like, that's a real law firm.
但当她说出那家律所的名字时，马歇尔说：“那是一家真正的律所。”
Nice.
太棒了。
Nicely done.
干得漂亮。
It's so fun knowing he's wrong.
知道他猜错了真的很有趣。
And I mean, I think Chris Harris wrote this episode.
我是说，我觉得这集是克里斯·哈里斯（Chris Harris）写的。
He's very funny.
他非常搞笑。
But I think this particular joke was Stephen Lloyd, who's another truly genius, him, him writer.
但我觉得这个特定的笑话是斯蒂芬·劳埃德（Stephen Lloyd）想出来的，他也是个真正的大牛，是个天才编剧。
And he was almost on all nine seasons.
而且他几乎参与了全部九季。
Like we can't quite say that about him.
我们对其他人可不能完全这么说。
Courtney Kang and Chris were door to door pilot to Finale.
考特尼·康（Courtney Kang）和克里斯是从头到尾都参与了。
But Stephen Lloyd joined a little, somewhere in the middle of season one.
但斯蒂芬·劳埃德是在第一季中途才加入的。
And I believe pitched this joke from that mistake in where she says, the thing about talking about anal, right?
我坚信这个笑话是他提出来的，就是那个口误的桥段，她谈论肛交那段，对吧？
Where she says, it's some guy riding me all day, talking about anal, we were so deliriously happy that we got that under the radar of some of the sensors.
她说：“有个家伙整天骑在我身上，满嘴都是肛交，”我们当时简直高兴疯了，竟然能在审查人员的眼皮底下蒙混过关。
And I think we did talk, I think we did talk about it with them.
我想我们确实跟他们沟通过，我想是的。
And we said, but it's not, it's not that she really, she's not a prostitute.
我们说：“但这并不是……并不是她真的……她其实不是个妓女。”
Like you aren't, the logic of it is how we got it on there.
就靠这种逻辑我们才把它播出来的。
Like the sensors had to have been having a good day that day for that to get through, because there were other jokes I think that were so much less risque, that were dinged, you know?
审查人员那天肯定心情不错，这才能放过这台词，因为我觉得有些没那么带颜色的笑话反而被掐了，你知道吗？
But the fact that that got through is incredible to me.
但能把这台词放过，我觉得简直不可思议。
Amazing.
太神奇了。
I also love when Ted says, when she says, you know, I've been, whatever, since I was 16, I'm going on dates and he says, God, you were just a kid.
我还很喜欢泰德说的，当她说：“你知道的，我从16岁起就一直在约会，”然后他说：“天哪，你当时还是个孩子。”
Like, I just really made me look.
这句话真的让我眼前一亮。
That scene is so great.
那场戏太棒了。
And Pam, that long walk-and-talk down that hall, but that was all the wonder, right?
还有潘，沿着走廊那段长长的移动长镜头，那全都是奇迹，对吧？
That's one camera pulling back.
那是单摄像机拉远。
I remember dallying back, it's just, again, we had time, we had no audience, fantastic.
我记得当时在倒退着走，就是，再次说明，我们有时间，没有现场观众，太棒了。
Right, and we can make a big, long hallway set like that, that aid up way too much real estate on a stage for a few out of eight years.
没错，我们能搭建一个那样又大又长的走廊布景，虽然在好几年里它在片场占用了太多地方。
It all comes back, so much comes back to that.
这一切都历历在目，很多回忆都跟那有关。
What else jumps out to you, Pam, of remembering the sense memory of directing this one, like a shot like that?
潘，回想起导演这一集的感官记忆，还有什么让你印象深刻的？比如像那种镜头？
A lot of laughing is really, is really what I'm remembering and I'm remembering just the pain in the neck of shooting that round table with everybody.
其实就是一直在笑，我记忆中最多的就是笑，还有拍那场所有人围坐在圆桌前的戏简直是个折磨。
There were so many set ups.
机位设置太多了。
Was there a huge fourth wall?
当时是不是拆了很大一块第四堵墙？
A huge fourth wall was put up, obviously, but like, so that became fully enclosed, huge.
显然搭起了一面巨大的第四堵墙，所以那个空间变得完全封闭了，超级大。
And I'm thinking back to when you were just starting this podcast and you had the audacity to talk about the limo and say, was it just a limo?
我回想起你刚开始做这个播客的时候，你居然有胆量谈起那辆加长林肯，还说：“那真的只是一辆林肯吗？”
And I'm like, oh my God, how did they not remember the limo for longest week of my life?
当时我就想，天哪，他们怎么会把“我人生中最漫长的一周”里的那辆林肯给忘了呢？
Yeah, I said, Pam will correct this when you're on the show.
对啊，我说：“等你上节目的时候，潘会纠正这个的。”
So tell us about the shooting the limo.
那就跟我们讲讲拍摄加长林肯的经历吧。
We had all sorts of different ways to shoot, right?
我们有各种各样的拍摄方式，对吧？
We had many, we had the front, we had the back.
我们有许多部分，有前段，有后段。
Everything was on wheels.
所有东西都在轮子上。
We had rolling things.
我们有滑轮装置。
It was a chopped up car and there was sections, right?
那是一辆被切成碎块的车，分成好几个部分，对吧？
Is that what you're saying?
你是这意思吗？
Yes, it was the, don't worry, it's a simple episode next week, Luna.
对，就是那个……别担心，露娜，下周会是个轻松的单集。
Yeah.
对啊。
Like I said, we were young and stupid.
就像我说的，我们当时又年轻又愚蠢。
The young and stupidness is a big theme of this episode of the podcast.
“又年轻又愚蠢”成了本期播客的一个核心主题。
Turned out to be one of the all-time great episodes, so thank you.
结果它成了史上最棒的剧集之一，所以谢谢你们。
You know what else?
你知道吗？
It strikes me for both of you about this episode.
关于这一集，你们俩还有什么让我感触很深的地方？
I so often find that certain episodes themselves can be treacle cutters, like after drum roll, please, you have zip, zip, zip, which is a much more, much lighter kind of episode.
我经常发现某些剧集本身就能起到缓冲剂的作用，比如在《鼓点请敲响》（Drumroll, Please）之后，紧接着就是《零、零、零》（Zip, Zip, Zip），这是一集节奏明快得多的剧集。
It's kind of a palette cleanser from the more serious stuff.
它就像是洗涤观众味蕾的清口菜，用来过渡那些更严肃的剧情。
After nothing good happens after two a.m., you have this episode, which is just more like hard comedy.
在《凌晨两点后无好事》（Nothing Good Happens After 2 A.M.）之后，你迎来了这一集，它更偏向于硬核喜剧。
Like this is just like a really funny episode that has its tear jerking moments or a heart tugging moments.
这就好像是一集纯粹搞笑的剧集，但同时也有让人泪目或揪心的时刻。
Like, you know, I was really Ted's face, I know it was my face, but Ted's face after he realizes Robin's gonna thank everyone, but him really, it's tough, it's sad, you know?
就像，你知道的，我真的看到泰德的脸——我知道那是我的脸——但在泰德意识到罗宾除了他之外要感谢所有人之后，那个表情真的很艰难，很伤感，你知道吗？
It's really sad, that moment.
那个时刻真的太伤感了。
I forgot how sad that moment was, but it's great, you needed it.
我都忘了那个时刻有多伤感了，但它很棒，剧情需要它。
It's what gives the show Robbie, right?
正是这些赋予了剧集血肉，对吧？
Those moments, Pam, those are the moments, right?
潘，就是这些时刻，这些时刻太关键了，对吧？
You have to, you can't rush through those.
你必须细细品味，不能草草带过。
And we didn't have to, those are the moments.
而我们确实没有草率处理，这些就是核心时刻。
And those are the moments I think that, that you and Sue and Carter and Craig, like you would, I'm watching, I'm noticing it more now.
而且我觉得正是这些时刻——你、苏（Sue）、卡特（Carter）和克雷格（Craig），你们会……我现在的感触越来越深了。
Like there's a lot of cut to a reaction of a person, you know, Kobe and me or Ted and Robin, like really having a mask up.
比如有很多切到某个人反应的镜头，你知道的，寇碧和我，或者泰德和罗宾，真的把伪装都卸下了。
Kobe in particular, I think, is just such a brilliant actor of like playing one thing but feeling another thing.
尤其是寇碧，我觉得她真是一位才华横溢的演员，能把表面一套和内心另一套的感觉演得淋漓尽致。
like she has a really great ability to like have her social mask up, but let the audience know that there's like something's roiling underneath.
她有一种超能力，既能戴着社交面具，又能让观众察觉到她内心深处有什么东西在翻涌。
And you guys really honored and preserved those moments in the edit, yeah.
而且你们在剪辑时真的非常尊重并保留了这些时刻，是的。
Yeah, Sue is really good at that too.
对，苏在这方面也很厉害。
Sue loved you all, just like Pam loved you all.
苏超级喜欢你们所有人，就像潘喜欢你们所有人一样。
Like everybody felt like so attuned to your guys' performances, even in a cutaway, even in a no-dialogue cutaway.
就像每个人都对你们的表演心领神会，哪怕只是一个切镜头，哪怕是一个没有台词的切镜头。
And I think that was a huge part of the success of the show.
我觉得这也是这部剧取得巨大成功的重要原因。
And Pamela, you made it all happen.
而帕梅拉，这一切都是你促成的。
I'm glad Sue would come down to the set and spend some time with us because she would tell me like I have such an intimate relationship with you guys, but I don't you don't know me that well Like I'm I'm I'm locked in a room with you guys all day long.
我很高兴苏能来到片场陪我们一会儿，因为她会告诉我，比如我对你们有这么亲密的联系，但我并不——你们其实并不太了解我。就像我——我整天都被关在一个房间里陪着你们。
I watch you Night, I know how she feels.
我看着你们的夜晚，我知道她的感受。
It's sure What a pleasure guys.
真是太棒了，伙计们，真荣幸。
We love you.
我们爱你们。
Thank you for being here I love you too.
谢谢你们来到这里，我也爱你们。
I love you so much.
我太爱你们了。
Because of you.
都是因为你们。
And it can't be overstated how you being the 99.9% director of the show made it what it was.
怎么强调都不为过，作为这部剧 99.9% 的导演，你造就了这部剧今天的模样。
Thank you so much for being with us today.
非常感谢今天能和我们在一起。
And always.
一直以来也是。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Thanks for making it.
谢谢你们创作了它。
Pam for I'm and we love you.
帕姆，我们爱你。
Well that was just delightful.
这真是太美妙了。
What a treat to have Pam for I'm in any part of your day.
今天能有帕姆加入我们的任何环节，真是一种享受。
day is better when Pam is a part of that day.
有了帕姆的加入，这一天都会变得更好。
We need a small part of the day.
我们需要一小部分时间的陪伴。
It's just brighter, brighter day.
这会让日子更明亮，更美好。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, thanks, Pam.
好吧，谢谢你，帕姆。
We love you.
我们爱你。
Please come back soon.
请常来。
And for the last section of the show, we like to close out with a letter, a written letter.
至于节目的最后一个环节，我们喜欢用一封信，一封手写的信来收尾。
We often open the show with a voice note and we close with a written letter.
我们通常用语音便签开场，然后用一封写好的信收尾。
If you would like to contribute either, please go to how we made your mother dot com you can also go to h y no h w m y m h w m y m that's a dot com and go to contact and just follow the links it should be pretty clear if you want to submit something we love to hear from you we love to hear what the show is meant to you and why you're still watching it after all these years if you're showing your kids like all the stuff we love it all so I just got back from Ecuador I was in Ecuador for a couple days for a Comic Con down there that was totally delightful.
如果你想贡献其中任何一个，请访问 how we made your mother dot com，你也可以访问 h y no h w m y m h w m y m，也就是点com，然后点击联系方式，按照链接操作，如果你想提交一些东西，应该会很清楚，我们喜欢听取你们的意见，我们喜欢听听这部剧对你们意味着什么，为什么历经这么多年你们还在看它，如果你把这部剧推荐给你的孩子们，所有这些，我们都非常喜欢，所以我刚从厄瓜多尔回来，我在厄瓜多尔待了几天，去那里的漫展，那真的非常愉快。
I just loved being down in Guayaquil, is that, I think that's where I was, but the people were so wonderful and the enthusiasm for the show and, you know, wonderfully for me, for other stuff I've made, but it was really wonderful to connect with so many how I met your mother fans.
我特别喜欢瓜亚基尔，是这样吗，我想我当时就在那里，但那里的人们太好了，对这部剧的热情，你知道，令我惊喜的是，还有我制作的其他作品，能与这么多《老爸老妈的浪漫史》粉丝交流真的非常美妙。
I think Craig, doing this show has, you know, when Pam said I'm a fan too, like it's really helping me become a fan of the show.
我觉得克雷格，做这个节目，你知道的，当帕姆说我也是个粉丝时，这真的帮我成了一个节目的粉丝。
I mean, I was a fan while we were making it, but it was so, it's so hard when you're so up close to it, I'm just finding the distance from it in the years, have really softened my ability to look at it with like fresh and loving eyes, and also really appreciate when people, I mean, I can't tell you the amount of people who said, this changed my life, this show taught me everything about love and the opening testimonial we got.
我的意思是，我们在制作的时候我是个粉丝，但当你身处其中时太难了，我只是发现时间的距离和岁月的沉淀，真的让我能够用崭新而充满爱意的目光去看待它，并且真正感激当人们——我的意思是，我无法告诉你有多少人说过，这改变了我的生活，这部剧教会了我关于爱的一切，以及我们收到的开场感言。
I'm so perpetually moved, and it does sound like people are saying maybe the same thing, it's not.
我永远都感动不已，听起来大家好像都在说同样的话，其实不然。
If you listen, there's a lot of different varieties of this theme, but the theme holds true.
如果你仔细听，这个主题有很多不同的变体，但主题始终如一。
This show met me at the right moment, a woman told me after a suicide attempt, this was the show that pulled her out of her depression.
这部剧在最恰当的时刻走进了我的生活，一位女士在一次自杀未遂后告诉我，是这部剧把她从抑郁中拉了出来。
You don't realize that when you're making a comedy that has some heart to it, that feels honest, that also has some big laughs, some people you want to spend time with, it's life affirming in the deepest way and people want to return to it.
当你制作一部既走心、真诚、又能带来欢笑、里面有你想与之共度时光的人的喜剧时，你不会意识到它具有最深层的抚慰人心的力量，人们总是想要重温它。
They want to spend time.
他们想要共度时光。
It makes you feel like this Earth place is hard, but it's an okay place to be.
它让你觉得地球这个地方虽然艰难，但还是个挺不错的地方。
Yeah, and it sounds like a prepackaged idea, that idea of, oh, it belongs to the fans now.
是的，这听起来像是一个预先包装好的概念，那种“哦，它现在属于粉丝了”的想法。
I really understand how profound that is at this point.
到了这个时候，我真的深刻理解了这句话的含义。
I've heard Mark Hamill talk about in interviews about Star Wars.
我听马克·哈米尔在采访中谈到过《星球大战》。
He's like, I'm just honored to talk about this thing with the people it belongs to now.
他说，我很荣幸能和这些现在拥有这部作品的人谈论它。
And it's like, that's how much mother is now and what an honor that it books.
这就好比现在的“老爸老妈”一样，这是一种多么大的荣幸啊。
And it belongs to everyone in a different way.
它以不同的方式属于每一个人。
It meets them in some different way.
它在不同的方面触动了他们。
And I'm really understanding that because of this podcast, I think, at an under duper level.
我想，正是因为这个播客，我正在以一种更深层次的方式理解这一点。
If someone comes up to us and says, I've watched the show 20 times front to back, There can be no question, they know the show better than we know it.
如果有人走过来对我们说，我从头到尾看了这部剧20遍，毫无疑问，他们对这部剧的了解比我们还深。
They know it.
他们太懂了。
Remember when I said, oh, why'd they cut that line, nerds who suck at math, life's gonna be rough boys.
还记得我说过吗，“哦，他们为什么要剪掉那句台词，不擅长数学的书呆子们，生活会很难过的，男孩们。”
I thought it was outside the club.
我以为那是俱乐部外面的事。
And all these people were like, that's from Best Prom Ever.
然后所有这些人都在说，那是出自《史上最佳毕业舞会》。
You know, like they know immediately.
你知道的，他们立刻就知道了。
That's Best Prom Ever.
那是《史上最佳毕业舞会》。
I know.
我知道。
I didn't catch that at her either.
我当时也没注意到她的那个。
I know.
我知道。
I've been corrected on that since, too.
之后我也因此被人纠正过。
Yeah.
是的。
I think I mentioned this, but when Selena Gomez posted just how I met your mother on her laptop, just the five of us sitting around talking at the bar, and I wrote in, what episode is this?
我想我提过这个，当赛琳娜·戈麦斯在她的笔记本电脑上播放《老爸老妈的浪漫史》时，正是我们五个人坐在酒吧里聊天的画面，我留言问，这是哪一集？
Because I was curious.
因为我很好奇。
And all these people wrote back, they knew.
结果所有这些人都回信了，他们都知道。
How did they know?
他们怎么知道的？
Our clothes that we were wearing.
凭我们当时穿的衣服。
That's how they knew.
他们就是这么知道的。
Because there was just beers on the table.
因为桌上只有啤酒。
There was nothing signifying it.
没有什么明显的标志。
I mean, just bananas.
我的意思是，太疯狂了。
I just love it.
我太喜欢了。
Kimmy and the fans are the best and the smartest and the coolest.
基米和粉丝们是最棒的、最聪明的、最酷的。
Yeah, so I met a ton of them in Ecuador.
是的，我在厄瓜多尔遇到了成千上万的粉丝。
I had such a lovely time and someone handed me this note and I only read it later, either later that night or the next day.
我度过了一段非常美好的时光，有人把这张便签递给了我，我是后来才看的，要么是那天深夜，要么是第二天。
Okay, I've not heard it, lay it on us.
好吧，我还没听过，快念给我们听听。
This is someone who wrote me in Ecuador and hand-delivered me this note and this is what they said, hi, Josh, you don't know me but I wanted to write this letter from the bottom of my heart.
这是我在厄瓜多尔时有人写给我并亲手交给我的一封信，内容是这样的：嗨，乔治，你可能不认识我，但我还是想发自内心地写下这封信。
I'm a content creator from Ecuador, not just a fan of yours, but someone who truly admires the beautiful person you are and how your character Ted Mosby has deeply influenced my life.
我是厄瓜多尔的一名内容创作者，不仅仅是你的粉丝，更是一个真心钦佩你这个美好的人、以及你的角色泰德·莫斯比如何深刻影响我生活的人。
I have dreamed of meeting you for a long time, mostly because of someone very special to me.
我梦想见到你很久了，主要是因为一个对我很特别的人。
His name was Alejandro.
他叫亚历杭德罗。
He was a mechatronics engineer who worked at Unilever.
他是一名在联合利华工作的机电工程师。
And earlier this year in January, he tragically passed away in the ocean, caught in a whirlpool.
今年年初的1月，他不幸在海洋中遭遇漩涡而离世。
Alejandro wasn't just a friend.
亚历杭德罗不仅仅是一个朋友。
He was someone I loved, first as a teenage partner when I was 15, and later as a truly close friend.
他是我深爱的人，最初在我15岁时是少年的伴侣，后来成了真正亲密的朋友。
One of the strongest bonds we shared was how I met your mother.
我们之间最深的羁绊之一就是《老爸老妈的浪漫史》。
He introduced me to the show, and for years we'd talk about it, especially about Ted.
是他带我入坑这部剧的，多年来我们一直在讨论它，尤其是关于泰德。
We saw ourselves in him, always torn between wanting to be with someone, learning to be alone, and holding onto the hope of a beautiful love.
我们在他身上看到了自己的影子，总是在渴望与某人在一起、学会独自一人、以及对美好爱情的希望之间挣扎。
We often talked about how Ted's journey mirrored so much of what we were learning in life, emotional growth, letting go, timing, heartbreak, and still believing in love no matter what.
我们经常谈论泰德的旅程如何反映了我们在生活中学到的很多东西：情感成长、放手、时机、心碎，以及无论如何依然相信爱情。
Thank you for giving life to a character who wasn't perfect, but who grew, who let go, who learned, who hoped.
感谢你赋予了一个并不完美、但却在成长、在放手、在学习、在抱有希望的角色以生命。
Thank you for showing that love is not always linear but always worth it.
谢谢你向我们展示了爱情并不总是笔直的，但永远都值得。
That friends can heal you, that change is constant and that trusting love is always a brave thing to do.
朋友可以治愈你，变化是不变的，而对爱情保持信任永远是一件勇敢的事。
I admire you deeply, Josh, not just as an actor but as a human being.
我深深地钦佩你，乔治，不仅仅作为一名演员，更作为一个真正的人。
Thank you for being here and thank you for coming to Ecuador.
谢谢你来到这里，谢谢你来到厄瓜多尔。
It's a beautiful country full of warmth and magic.
这是一个充满温暖和魔力的美丽国家。
I truly hope you get to experience more of it.
我真心希望你能体验到更多这里的风情。
This letter is part of my way of honoring Alejandro.
这封信是我纪念亚历杭德罗的方式的一部分。
I know wherever he is, he's probably jumping with joy, knowing I got to do this to meet you, a dream we shared.
我知道无论他在哪里，他可能都在高兴得直跳，因为知道我做到了这一切——见到了你，这是我们共同的梦想。
I hope this letter brings you even a fraction of what your work has meant to me with love and admiration, Millie Michon.
希望这封信能带给你一丝慰藉，让你知道你的作品对我有多大意义。带着爱与崇敬，米莉·米雄。
My gosh, that's unbelievable.
天哪，这太难以置信了。
That's so beautiful, thank you for that letter.
太美了，谢谢你分享这封信。
like I love love isn't always linear, but it's always worth it.
就像我说的，爱情并不总是笔直的，但永远值得。
It's incredible.
这太不可思议了。
It's incredibly well written letter in addition to just being so nice of them to share.
除了他们分享的这份善意，这是一封写得极其出色的信。
Yeah, quite beautiful, like quite a soulful person.
是的，挺美的，就像是一个很有灵魂的人。
And yeah, just, you know, I hear from people like, we fell in love over the show or my friend and I went deeper in our friendship because of this show.
而且，你知道的，我经常听到有人说，我们因为这部剧而坠入爱河，或者我和朋友因为这部剧加深了友谊。
And, you know, I also, I really love at the time, time, it was hard for me to play such a vulnerable, flawed character.
而且，你知道，我也真的很喜欢——当时，对我来说，扮演这样一个脆弱、有缺陷的角色其实很难。
I felt like I had to let people see these, you know, it was me and not me, right?
我觉得我不得不让人们看到这些，你知道的，那是“我”又不是“我”，对吧？
I had to let them see these parts of me that I was little like, or a little embarrassed about or a little like, no, these are parts of me.
我不得不让他们看到我身上这些部分，其实我心里有点……或者有点尴尬，或者觉得，不，这些都是我的一部分。
I don't reveal all that regularly.
我并不经常把这些展现出来。
But then I was asked to do it in front of millions of people every week.
但随后我却被要求每周在数百万观众面前这样做。
And to now see 20 years later that that's the very thing that people latch on to and respond to and love so much, his imperfections.
而现在，20年后看到，正是这一点让人们紧紧抓住、产生共鸣并如此喜爱，也就是他的不完美。
I've said this quote, but when we talk about our accomplishments, it breeds competition.
我说过这样一句话，当我们谈论我们的成就时，它会滋生竞争。
When we talk about our vulnerability, it breeds community.
当我们谈论我们的脆弱时，它会滋生社群。
So, I think there's, there's just, you know, Ted is like, I think he's a classic character because he was so wrong so often, you know, he was so much like us.
所以，我觉得，你知道的，泰德就像是一个经典角色，因为他经常犯错，你知道的，他跟我们太像了。
He was, he was, he was drawing erroneous conclusions.
他总是得出错误的结论。
He was thinking the paralegal was a prostitute, you know, he was just constantly stepping on Rakes to reference the Simpsons we were talking about earlier.
他以为那个律所助理是个妓女，你知道的，他就像我们刚才提到的《辛普森一家》那样，不断地踩钉耙。
But he also, he, he, he believed in, in, in love, he believed in his friends.
但同时，他也相信爱，相信他的朋友。
He ultimately ends up believing in himself and it was an honor and an honor to have played a part in people's lives, I can't overstate that.
他最终开始相信自己，能够在人们的生活中扮演这样一个角色是一种荣幸，对此我怎么强调都不为过。
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《How We Made Your Mother》由乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）和克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）主持并担任执行制片人。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Madica.
本节目由我（亚历克·莱夫，Alec Lev）制作，我们的联合制片人是道格·马迪卡（Doug Madica）。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios, and our digital content producer AKA Gen Z Master is Emily Blumber.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的亚历克斯·里夫斯（Alex Reeves），我们的数字内容制作人兼“Z世代大师”是埃米莉·布伦伯（Emily Blumber）。
Artwork by John Morrow.
封面艺术由约翰·莫罗（John Morrow）创作。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这确实对节目非常有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majewski.
我们的主题曲是《NYC》，由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作，克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马杰夫斯基（Andrew Majewski）提供额外音乐。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萝拉·肯尼迪（Lola Kennedy）和埃利奥特·康纳斯（Elliot Connors）。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to sign up for our sub-stack mailing list and for links to our social media.
访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 注册我们的 Substack 邮件列表，并获取我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您也可以点击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Want some merch?
想要一些周边商品吗？
Click on the store link or go to HowYouGetYourMerch.com.
点击商店链接或访问 HowYouGetYourMerch.com。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack, order Craig Thomas' debut novel at CraigThomasRider.com slash novel, and you could subscribe to my Dead Father's Society, also on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳的 Muse Letters，在 CraigThomasRider.com/novel 订购克雷格·托马斯的首部小说，你还可以订阅我的 Dead Father's Society（同样在 Substack 上）。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research.
要了解如何为本节目旨在为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的长期活动贡献力量，
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
请查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”标签页。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures.
本集节目得到了 Backyard Ventures 的大力支持。
People will, in fact, dance.
人们事实上确实会跳舞。
Real question, it just hit me, am I in love, or just New York City?
一个真正的问题，我刚刚突然想到的，我是恋爱了，还是仅仅爱上了纽约市？